ओके गाइस
सो चलिए तो लाइव हम आ चुके
हैं राइट नाउ वी आर लाइव नाउ ओके तो हम
लाइव आ चुके हैं
चलिए लेट्स सी हां जी तो चलिए काफी लोग आ
चुके हैं यहां पे काफी लोग जुड़ चुके हैं
तो आने देते हैं सभी को हेलो हेलो एवरी
बडी हेलो क्या हाल चाल है सबके कैसे हैं
सब बढ़िया सब मजे में सब टकाटक बता दीजिए
एक बार ऑडियो वीडियो सब क्लियर है आप लोग
प्लीज बता दीजिए एक बार ऑडियो वीडियो
एवरीथिंग इज क्लियर प्लीज बता दीजिए गाइस
एवरीबॉडी
हेलो हां
जी अ बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बहुत 30 लोग आ चुके
हैं बाकी सभी को आ जाने देते हैं लास्ट
सेशन में तो काफी धमाका कर दिया था आप
लोगों ने नंबर ऑफ व्यूवर्स के मैटर में
150 से ज्यादा व्यूवर्स ने हमें जॉइन किया
था तो आज देखते हैं आज क्या धमाका होता है
फिलहाल सभी को आने देते हैं देखते हैं
नोटिफिकेशन का अभी जाएगी शायद अभी करेंटली
नोटिफिकेशन भी नहीं गई होगी शायद क्योंकि
जस्ट हम लाइव आए हुए हैं तो थोड़ा वेट कर
लेते हैं सभी के आने सभी के आने का वेट कर
लेते हैं
थोड़ा
हम जी
हां वेलकम वेलकम धन्यवाद भाई धन्यवाद पहले
बता दीजिए ऑडियो वीडियो सब क्लियर है
वे ऑडियो एकदम क्लियर है ऑडियो वीडियो
बिल्कुल क्लियर है ना कोई कोई प्रॉब्लम तो
नहीं है सभी को आ आने देते हैं एक
बार हां ठीक है आवाज तेज आ रही है चलिए
बहुत बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया गुड इवनिंग जय
श्री कृष्ण जय श्री कृष्ण भाई नमस्कार सब
लोगों को एंड वेल आई गॉट एट वैलिड बक्स
ब्रो आई एम अबाउट टू रीच 10 एंड दोज आर
वैलिड ये इट्स p5 ग्रेट ग्रेट
कांग्रेचुलेशन नौ सिखिया एंड आपको एट
वैलिड बग्स मिल रहे हैं
दैट्ची बात ठीक है वैलिड बग मिलने चाहिए
चाहे वो p5 हो p4 हो डजन मैटर वैलिड बग है
तो आपके अंदर एक इनकरेजमेंट आती है एक
उत्साह आता है एक जो है हिम्मत आती है वो
हिम्मत जो है आपको फिर नेक्स्ट लेवल पे
लेकर जाती है आपको ठीक है तो ये आप हमेशा
ध्यान रखिएगा गुड इवनिंग सबको सबको सबको
गुड इवनिंग सर मुझे अ ओके फर्स्ट टाइम
स्टूडेंट आई एम लाइव डे 16 स्टूडेंट क्या
बात है क्या बात है अलीशान क्लासिंग अ
कांग्रेचुलेशन डिफ्रॉक जिंदाबाद अरे ललित
जिंदाबाद
सर डीसीएसपी नेक्स्ट कोर्स कब आंसर प्लीज
नेक्स्ट मंथ में आएगी य सितंबर एंड में या
सितंबर एंड में ही मोस्ट प्रोबेबली लंच
होगी सर वाउचर नहीं दिया कौन सा वाउचर भाई
कौन सा वाउचर गिव अवे में पार्टिसिपेट
किया होगा तो विनर्स को मिले थे ओनली सबको
तो नहीं दे पाऊंगा
मैं ओके
ग्रेट ओके यस फायर बांटी पर कंपनी रिप्लाई
नहीं दे रही है सर हां फायर बांटी प बहुत
सारे कंपनीज जो हैं वो थोड़े से लाइक
सुस्त टाइप बहुत सारे कंपनीज आपको रिप्लाई
शायद ना भी दे तो ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेना
है जस्ट कीप रिपोर्टिंग एंड वैलिड हो तो
बढ़िया है वैलिड मिलने चाहिए ठीक
है सर आज 200 प्लस हो जाएगा लाइव अरे ये
तो मुझे नहीं लगता है बट स्टिल देखते हैं
देखते हैं 100 प्लस भी हो जाए आज भी तो
काफी है बट 200 प्लस तो शायद पॉसिबल नहीं
है 200 प्लस लाइव आ जाए लोग चलिए तो आज के
टॉपिक बहुत ही खतरनाक शानदार एंड बहुत ही
अमेजिंग होने वाली है आज की टॉपिक आपके बग
बाउंट जर्नी में भी हेल्प करेगी एंड साइबर
क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन में भी इसका आप यूज
कर सकते हैं एक तरह से ठीक है मैं आपको
सारी चीज बताऊंगा आज का टॉपिक बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग है एंड ये एक बहुत ही अच्छी
सीवियरिंग की वनबिल है जो मैं आपको डिस्कस
आज करने वाला हूं जो मैं आपको आज बताने
वाला हूं तो एंड तक पूरा बने रहिए जो भी
दोस्त या जो भी आपके कलीग या जो भी दोस्त
या रिलेटिव्स है जो भी है ना इस दुनिया
में पूरे इस धरती पे जो एजिस्ट करते हैं
जिनका साइबर सिक्योरिटी से ज्यादा सा भी
इंटरेस्ट है या मतलब है या थोड़ी भी उनको
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में इंटरेस्ट दिखाते हैं
आपसे बातें करते हैं तो उनको हमारी
वीडियोस को शेयर कीजिए हमारे चैनल को जो
है शेयर कीजिए बताइए हमारे चैनल के बारे
में एंड इस बग बाउटी के लाइव सेशन के बारे
में क्योंकि हम एक और फ्री कोर्स जल्दी ही
अनाउंस करने वाले हैं लाइव ट्रेनिंग फ्री
एंड वो जो फ्री ट्रेनिंग हम एक अनाउंस
करने वाले हैं गाइस मैं आपको पहले ही बता
देता हूं ठीक
है सर आपके youtube0 कोर्स से बग बाउंट कर
सकते हैं अरे भाई बग बाउंट के लिए ही यह
कोर्स है प्लीज बार-बार मैसेज कीजिएगा तो
आपको अ ब्लॉक कर दिया जाएगा यहां से तो
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम एनीवर्सरी
नहीं तो आप बैन हो जाएंगे ठीक है तो जी
हां आप कर सकते हैं उसी के लिए ये कोर्स
है और दूसरी बात यह है कि एक बहुत ही
शानदार आपके लिए एक प्रैक्टिकल कोर्स फिर
से लॉन्च होने वाली है बहुत जल्द हमारे
डेनिक्स के साइट से आप सबके लिए ये जो
सरप्राइज मैंने बोला था फ्री कोर्स की मैं
बात कर रहा हूं ठीक है वो लॉन्च होगी एंड
वो जो कोर्स होगी वो किस लेवल की होगी मैं
वो भी बता देता हूं उसके जो टॉपिक्स होंगे
वो आपके जो लाइक ईजेपी t वगैरह की
सर्टिफिकेशंस के बारे में आप जानते होंगे
उसका जो लेवल होता है ईजेपी t की
सर्टिफिकेशन की वर्जन टू की सर्टिफिकेशन
की लेवल जो होती है या पर्टिकुलर
प्रैक्टिकल सर्टिफिकेशंस जो अवेलेबल है
मार्केट में काफी पॉपुलर सर्टिफिकेशंस हैं
प्रैक्टिकल डैश प्रैक्टिकल करके है कुछ
कुछ प्रैक्टिकल करके है आप समझ रहे होंगे
तो अ मैं नाम नहीं ले सकता नहीं तो पता वो
सामने वाले लोग बेचारे कॉपीराइट मारने
लगते हैं तो इस वजह से बेकार है नाम लेना
उनका आप समझ गए होंगे मैं किस चीज की बात
कर रहा हूं कौन से प्रैक्टिकल की बात कर
रहा हूं प्रैक्टिकल सर्टिफिकेशन की बात कर
रहा हूं तो उसके और ई जेपीटी इन दोनों के
कंटेंट मिक्स्ड कंटेंट के ऊपर फ्री कोर्स
हमारा आने वाला है यानी कि जब आप इस कोर्स
को कर लेंगे थोड़ा टाइम ज्यादा लगेगा तो
आप उसके सर्टिफिकेशन डायरेक्ट भी अटेंप्ट
कर सकते हैं मैं इतना आपको बोल सकता हूं
तो
दैट्ची बिल्कुल सही जवाब
है बिल्कुल सही जवाब
है आप गेस कर रहे हैं ना आप कौन सी मैं
कोर्स की बात कर रहा हूं चलिए ठीक है चलिए
तो अभी अ स्टार्ट करते हैं आज के हम
क्लासेस को उसके पहले सबसे पहले मैं आपको
सिंपल बता देता हूं
linkedin.com
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर यह मेरी प्रोफाइल है
फॉलो करने के लिए मेरी जर्नी के साथ
जुड़ने के लिए जो भी मेरी जर्नी आने वाली
है अभी होने वाली है सबके साथ यह हमारे
डेनिक्स की
linkedinsign.com के बारे में या जो भी
व्हाट एवर कंपनी से रिलेटेड यहां आपको मिल
जाएगा अ जो भी अपडेट्स वगैरह हैं या जो भी
चीजें हैं वो यहां मिल जाएगी एंड नेक्स्ट
वन इज कि ये हमारी वेबसाइट है de.com तो
यहां पे आपको अ जो है अ सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग जो है आपको
मिलती रहेंगी अपकमिंग बैचेज वगैरह के
रिक्वायरमेंट्स या सब कुछ जो डिटेल्स है
मिलती रहेंगी दूसरी एक और इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
है ये है कि हमारी लाइक
जरूर से जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा वो है
डिफ्रॉक साइबर वरियर्स ये चैनल आपको यहां
पे दिख रहा होगा ठीक है तो रॉनिक साइबर
वरियर्स इस चैनल का लिंक आपको हर वीडियो
के हर जो भी बग बाउंट की वीडियोस या जो भी
वीडियोस आती है ना आपकी जैसे आज की वीडियो
है डे 43 या डे 42 41 हर वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जब आप जाएंगे ठीक है
भैया डिस्क्रिप्शन में तो वहां पे ना
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाएंगे तो वहां पे हमारी
इस चैनल का लिंक मिल जाएगा एंड हमारे
डेनिक्स बग हंटर के
तो आप उसको भी जवाइन कर सकते हैं एंड एट द
आप उसको भी जवाइन कर सकते हैं यहां पे इस
तरीके से इस चैनल को फॉलो कर सकते हैं
यहां पे उसके बाद यहां पे जो डेनिक्स की
एंड नेक्स्ट इज आप हमारी डेनिक्स अकेडमी
जो एंड्र पप है आप इसको इंस्टॉल करके यहां
पर आप हमारी कोर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं ठीक है यह सारी चीजें आप हमारे
प्लेटफॉर्म प आके इनसे जुड़ के कर सकते
हैं चलिए तो आज की जो क्लास है वो स्टार्ट
करते हैं बहुत ही धमाकेदार सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं बहुत ही मजा आने वाला है
आपको आज के सेशन में क्योंकि आज के सेशन
में ना हम बहुत एक इंपॉर्टेंट इंफो के ऊपर
बात करेंगे एंड वो है एफ
डाटा वो है एफ डाटा ठीक है वो है क्या है
डाटा अब इसका एकदम सिंपल सा मैं आपको वो
देता हूं एग्जांपल मैं चलता हूं चैट
जीपीटी पे ठीक है मैं चलता हूं चैट जीपीटी
पे मैं यहां पे सिंपल इससे पूछता हूं
व्हाट इज व्हाट इज एजिप डाटा क्या बात है
आज आज भी 97 आ गए क्या बात है भाई अरे
रिकॉर्ड पे रिकॉर्ड बना रहे यार तुम लोग
यार ये मुझे उम्मीद तो नहीं होती है लेकिन
ठीक है ये 93 लोग आ गए आज भी मतलब 100 आज
भी होने वाले हैं क्या बात है थोड़ी सी
क्वेश्चंस ले लेते हैं फिर स्टार्ट करते
हैं सर रिमेंबर मी आई हैड कंप्लीटेड टिल
डे 20 एंड की पोस्टिंग एवरीथिंग ऑन लिंकन
आल्सो टैग्ड यू इन यस आयुष मोरे या वेरी
गुड गोइंग आयुष मोरे आयुष काफी सारे जो भी
बग बाउटी में करते हैं वो मोस्टली पोस्ट
करते हैं मटक करते हैं दैट्ची
है सर आपका सीटीएफ प्लेटफॉर्म कब स्टार्ट
होगा बहुत जल्द हम लच करेंगे थोड़ा टाइम
डिले हो रहा है बस और कुछ नहीं फ्रंट एंड
के वजह से सर मैं अभी इससे प्लेलिस्ट
स्टार्ट नहीं किया क्योंकि अभी भी आपका सी
कोर्स कर रहा हूं बाद में आपके बग बाउंट
का प्लेलिस्ट बिल्कुल बिल्कुल चलेगा कोई
दिक्कत नहीं चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है बांग्लादेश के कुछ हां कुछ अटैक्स
वगैरह हो रहे हैं कुछ अटैक्स वगैरह हो रहे
हैं क्या बात है पहले तो बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद आप लोग 92 यहां पे 92 पीपल आर
हियर अप्रॉक्स तो चलिए अच्छी बात है आप
लोग समझ रहे हैं अभी आते हैं लाइव में
पहले सर्च करते हैं यहां पे व्हाट इज मतलब
इससे पूछते हैं भाई व्हाट इज एसिफें चैर
जीपीटी से पूछा है कि चैर जीपीटी भैया
हमें कुछ नहीं पता है क्या है क्या है
व्हाट इज एजिप डेटा थोड़ा बताओ ठीक
है तो यहां पे हमने पूछा इसे
सॉरी कि व्हाट इज एजिप डाटा ठीक है तो
मैंने क्या किया मैं यहां पे
अ यह वाला मान लो रिस्पांस वन आया
रिस्पांस टू आया अ कुछ भी कोई सा भी
रिस्पांस आप चूज कर सकते हैं वो आपके उसके
लिए है तो मैं यहां पे मान लो कि यह वाला
रिस्पांस चूज कर लेता हूं अब यहां पे क्या
लिख रहे हैं एजिप डाटा व्हिच स्टैंड्स फॉर
एक्सचेंज बल इमेज फाइल फॉर्मेट इज अ
कलेक्शन ऑफ मेटा डाटा एंबेडेड विद इन
डिजिटल इमेजेस एंड ऑडियो फाइल्स ठीक है
मतलब डिजिटल इमेजेस जो होते हैं जो आप
फोटोज क्लिक करते हैं अपने फोन से अपने
स्मार्टफोन से अपने स्मार्ट डिवाइसेज से
उस फोटो के अंदर ना कुछ डाटा इंबेड हो
जाते हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट अब वो डाटा अलग-अलग
तरह के डाटा हो सकते हैं आपके कैमरा की
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है आपकी लोकेशन
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है डिवाइस की
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है सॉफ्टवेयर की
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन कैन बी कैप एंबेडेड इन दैट
डाटा इज एंबेडेड इन दैट डेटा दिस मेटा
डेटा प्रोवाइड्स डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट द
इमेज और ऑडियो फाइल उस इमेज ऑडियो फाइल की
इंफॉर्मेशन देते हैं इंक्लूडिंग टेक्निकल
एंड डिस्क्रिप्टिव डिटेल्स दैट कैन बी
यूज़फुल फॉर वेरियस पर्पसस सच एज
कैटालॉगिंग एडिटिंग एनालाइजिंग मीडिया
फाइल्स ये तो नॉर्मल सा डिफाइन कर दिया
इसने अब मैं आपको बताता हूं कि ये कितनी
ज्यादा डेंजरस हो सकती है आपके बग बाउंट
में ये क्यों ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है मैं
आपको लेके चलता हूं बग क्राउड प तभी तो
आपको मजा आएगा ठीक
है मैं आपको ले चलता हूं बक क्राउड
[संगीत]
प ओके मैं यहां पे पासवर्ड डाल देता
हूं चलिए मैं आपको बकड पर लेके चलता
हूं बकट प चलते हैं य प बक राउट में ना जब
आप बेसिकली कहां जाएंगे
चलिए होम पेज पर पहले चलते हैं लेट्स गो
टू द इंडेक्स पेज प्रोडक्ट्स ये लेबिलिटी
रेटिंग टैक्सनॉमी जो इनका पव प2 पी3
डिफाइन करता है किस तरीके से य डिफाइन
करते हैं इसमें बताते हैं ठीक है ना तो
वलने बिलिटी रेटिंग टेक्सोनोमी पर चलते
हैं वल बिलिटी रेटिंग टैक्सनॉमी आई होप की
ऑडियो क्लियर है सब कुछ है सब कुछ क्लियर
है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो वीटी पर चलते
हैं यहां
पीआरटी में जब आप आएंगे ना बक राउड के ऊपर
में तो जब यहां पर आप एक्सप्लोर करेंगे
इसको तो आपको पता चलेगा कि किस टाइप के
वलने एबिलिटी को किस कैटेगरी में टेक्निकल
सीवियरिंग उनका क्या डिफाइन करते हैं p1
इज द हाईएस्ट मोस्ट सीवियर मोस्ट सीवियर
लेबिलिटी p2 उससे कम उससे थ p3 उससे कम
उससे कम p4 एंड p5 इज इंफॉर्मेशन काइंड ऑफ
लेबिलिटी ठीक है अब यहां पे प जब इसमें आप
सर्च करेंगे एफ
एजिफिट वाली जो लेबिलिटी है एजिप
जिओलोकेशन डाटा नॉट स्ट्रिप्ड ऑफ फ्रॉम
अपलोडेड इमेजेस यह एक वलने बिलिटी आपको
दिखती है ये वलने बिलिटी p3 कैटेगरी में
है जी हां गाइस दिस वलने बिलिटी फॉल्स
अंडर p3 कैटेगरी ये कोई p4 p5 कैटेगरी
नहीं है दिस इज अंडर p3 कैटेगरी और p3
कैटेगरी के लिए बहुत सारी जो कंपनीज है
5500 बाउंट पे करती है आपको 5500 बाउंट पे
करती है सीरियसली मैं बता रहा हूं आपको
चलो ठीक है ये तो आपने देख लिया अब यहां
पे आते हैं इसमें क्या होता है ऑटोमेटिक
मतलब इसका इफेक्टेड फंक्शन क्या है
ऑटोमेटिक यूजर न्यूमरेशन या यूं कहे कि
इसमें आपका अ अ पर्सनल लाइक सेंसिटिव डाटा
एक्सपोजर होता है ठीक है सेंसिटिव डाटा
एक्सपोजर के अंदर में ही ये एजिप
जिओलोकेशन डाटा जिओलोकेशन डाटा नॉट
स्ट्रिप्ट फ्रॉम अपलोडेड इमेज ये चीज आती
है ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे इसको समझते हैं
कि ये काम कैसे करता है ये आखिर है क्या
ये एजिप जिओलोकेशन डटा स्क्रिप्ट ये सब ये
फंडा आखिर है क्या ये होता क्या है भाई
इसका इसका मतलब इससे हमें क्या वो है तो
मैं आपको ना एक चीज दिखाता हूं अभी मैं अ
फोन पे चलता हूं मैं आपको एक चीज ओपन कर
रहा हूं जस्ट गिव मी ए सेकंड ताकि मैं
आपको वो चीज दिखा
पाऊं ठीक है
लोकेशन
अ देन यहां पे चलते हैं
कैमरा हां जी अब यहां पे चलते हैं
लेट्स सी कैमरा पनो प चलते हैं यहां इनकी
परमिश पे चलते हैं एंड यहां पे लोकेशन पे
चलते हैं ठीक है चलिए अब मैं आपको ना यहां
पे एक चीज दिखा देता हूं ठीक है अब होता
क्या है यूजुअली मैं अपने ए फोन पे चलता
हूं पहले ए फोन पे यूजुअली क्या होता है
जैसे मेरा ये कैमरा एप्लीकेशन है ठीक है
तो मैं कैमरा एप्लीकेशन के इंफो पे चलता
हूं यहां पे इंफो में मैं चलूंगा यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा शायद इंफो आई थिंक अब
दिख गया
होगा ठीक है तो यहां यहां आप लोग ध्यान दे
दीजिए इंफो पे चलते हैं यहां पे परमिशन पे
चलते हैं सॉरी यहां परमिशन पे चलते हैं
परमिशन पे जब आप जाएंगे ना तो आपको यहां
पे दिखेगा कि अलाउड परमिशन में यहां पे एक
कैमरा है लोकेशन है माइक्रोफोन है फोटोज
एंड वीडियोस है ठीक है तो इसमें आप
देखेंगे कि लोकेशन का जो एक्सेस है इसको
अलाउड है लास्ट एक्सेस इसका 7:4 पे हुआ था
74 पीएम पे इसका लास्ट एक्सेस अब ये
लोकेशन पे जब आप टैप करेंगे ना तो यहां पे
आपको एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा यूज प्रिसा इज
लोकेशन इसका मतलब ये हुआ व्हेन प्रिसा इज
लोकेशन इज ऑफ ऐप कैन एक्सेस योर
एप्रोक्सीमेट लोकेशन अगर आप इसको ऑफ कर
देंगे तो ऐप एप्रोक्सीमेट आपका लोकेशन
एक्सेस कर पाएगा फिर भी कर पाएगा बट अगर
इसको आप ऑन रखते हैं ना इसका मतलब है जो
यह ऐप है है कैमरा यह आपकी एग्जैक्ट
लोकेशन एक्सेस कर सकता है आपकी एग्जैक्ट
लोकेशन आपकी इंबेड कर सकता है आपकी फोटोज
के साथ इसको इस चीज की परमिशन है तो हमारे
कैमरा एप्लीकेशन के पास जो होती है वोह
परमिशन होती है आपके लोकेशन की अब वही
लोकेशन एंड अदर सिस्टम डाटा या अदर
इंफॉर्मेशन आपके फोटो के साथ जो आप इस
कैमरे से क्लिक करते हैं जो आप इस फोन के
कैमरे से क्लिक करते हैं वो इंबेड हो जाती
है उसके साथ अब हम यह जानते हैं कि बाकी इ
बाकी जो डिटेल्स है उससे हमें ज्यादा कुछ
तो फर्क नहीं पड़ता है बाकी डिटेल्स अगर आ
भी जाती है चलो उसका भी यूज हो जाएगा बहुत
उसका भी बहुत तरह से यूज किया जा सकता है
बट स्टिल सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज जो है जो
मोस्ट डेंजरस चीज होती है एजिप डेटा या
एजिप मेटा डेटा की बात करें हम
मेटा इसको मेटा डटा बोलते हैं मेटा डेटा
मेटा डेटा क्या होता है गाइस मेटा डेटा का
सिंपल मतलब बताऊ ना डाटा
मैं ऐसे बोलता हूं डटा ऑफ डाटा ऑफ डेटा
डेटा का जो डाटा है वह मेटा डाटा है बात
खत्म मेटा डाटा वही है जो डेटा का डाटा है
वह मेटा डाटा है अब इसके अंदर ना मेटा
डाटा के अंदर बहुत सारी चीज आ जाती है
इसमें सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट होता है जिओ लोकेशन
जिओ लोकेशन अब जिओ लोकेशन का मतलब होता है
जिओ लोकेशन का लटटू
एंड जिओ का ल लोंगिट्यूड
लोंगी टू ट्यूडी लोंगिट्यूड ठीक है
स्पेलिंग देख लीजिएगा आप लोग लटटू एंड
लोंगिट्यूड ये आपकी दोनों जो है बहुत
ज्यादा एक इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन होती है
अब यहां पे क्या होता है जब ये इंबेड हो
जाते हैं अब हम जैसे मान लो कोई एक
वेबसाइट प चलते हैं कोई भी एक फाइल अपलोड
जहां पर आप कर सकते हैं उस वेबसाइट पे आप
जा सकते हैं कोई भी ऐसी प्लेटफॉर्म जहां
पे आप फाइल अपलोड करते हैं ठीक है भैया अब
आप जब फाइल अपलोड करते हैं कि किसी भी
प्लेटफार्म पे चाहे कहीं भी जो वहां पे
फाइल अपलोड करने का या इमेज सेट करने का
प्रोफाइल इमे या फोटो अपलोड करने का ऑप्शन
दिया गया है तो वहां पे आप चलते हैं जब
वहां पे आप जाते हैं वहां पे आप कोई फाइल
एक या कोई इमेज अपलोड करते हैं तो हम इमेज
जब अपलोड करते हैं ना तो वो जो पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट है या जो भी आपका टारगेट है या जो
भी आप जिस पे आप हंट कर रहे हैं जिस
पर्टिकुलर अ वेबसाइट पे जब आप हंट कर रहे
हैं अरे वाह 101 100 प्लस हो चुका है भैया
100 प्लस हो चुका है एंड कांग्रेचुलेशन
एंड धन्यवाद चलिए अब मजा आ रहा है तो उन
वेबसाइट्स का यह परम कर्तव्य होना चाहिए
उनका कर्तव्य क्या होना चाहिए उनका धर्म
क्या होना चाहिए कि जब आप अपनी कोई इमेज
उस वेबसाइट पर अपलोड करते हैं ठीक
है
और अ
वेबसाइट
च अ
नॉट वल्नरेबल
विथ इस वल्नरेबल का नाम क्या है इस
वल्नरेबल का नाम क्या
है
एजिप ये वाली य यहीं से ले लेते हैं यहीं
से ले लेते हैं हमारी बक राउट से ये
वाली इफ अ अ वेबसाइट नॉट वल्नरेबल विथ
एजिप जिओलोकेशन डाटा नॉट अ स्ट्रिप्ड
फ्रॉम अपलोडेड इमेजेज शुड शुड स्ट्रिप ऑफ
शुड स्ट्रिप शुड स्ट्रिप शुड स्ट्रिप द
द जिओ
लोकेशन
डाटा स्ट्रिप द
एक्सिफ जिओ लोकेशन डाटा फ्रॉम द अपलोडेड
इमेज ऑन देयर प्लेटफॉर्म ऑन देयर
प्लेटफॉर्म एंड व्हेन यूजर्स
रिट्राईंग व्हेन
यूजर्स
रिट्रैक्ट्स
प्राइवेट इंफॉर्मेशन
च मे वायलेट्स
पर्सन
प्राइवेसी पर्सन प्रीवे स ठीक है यह समझ
में आ गया होगा यह इतना बहुत सिंपल सा
फंडा है जो वेबसाइट वल्नरेबल नहीं होगी वह
वेबसाइट पर जब आप कोई भी इमेज अपलोड करते
हैं वहां पर वह वेबसाइट क्या करेगी आपके
उस इमेज से वो जो जिओ लोकेशन वाला पार्ट
है उसको स्ट्रिप करके हटा देगी जब आप
अपलोड करें तो और जब आप दोबारा उसको
डाउनलोड करेंगे उस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट से
तो वहां पर क्या होगा जो इमेज डाउनलोड
होगी उसमें कोई भी सेंसिटिव डाटा नहीं
होगी कोई भी जिओ लोकेशन डाटा नहीं होगी अब
मैं आपको यहां पर इसका एक लाइव एग्जांपल
दिखाता हूं कि यह काम एक्चुअली करती कैसी
है देखिए जैसे मैं यहां पर चलता
हूं ए इंफो कोई सा भी ओपन कर सकते
हैं चलिए एफ इंस्पेक्टर इंफो कोई सा भी
ओपन कर लीजिए यहां पर सारे ओपन कर लेते
हैं कोई सा भी यूज कर स स आप इसमें सबसे
ज्यादा पॉपुलर जो वेबसाइट है वो यह है .
reg.in बट यह क्या यह वेबसाइट जो है
बेसिकली डाउन है इन पे काफी ज्यादा लोड
पड़ गया वेबसाइट पे काफी पॉपुलर हो गई
जिसकी वजह से सर्वर के जो जो बैंडविथ के
खर्च है एक्सपेंस है वो इसके ओनर झेल नहीं
पाए बिकॉज फ्री था ये तो शायद अभी ये डाउन
चल रहा है बाकी बहुत सारी और वेबसाइट्स
हैं जैसे कि ये आपका ए lite.com है यह एक
य इन्होंने एक आर्टिकल के अंदर में यहां
पे धीरे से एक एप्लीकेशन जो है छुपा रखा
है उसके बाद यहां पे है एफ
info.com जो है ये भी काफी अच्छा है इसको
यूज भी कर सकते हैं उसके बाद पिक्ड भी यूज
कर सकते हैं एफ टूल जो है आप उसको भी यूज
कर सकते हैं एफ टूल भी है वो भी आप यूज कर
सकते हैं एफ टूल भी आता है अगर आप देखेंगे
एफ टूल करके यहां पे तो यहां पे आप एजिप
टूल भी जो है वो इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं
ठीक है इस ये एक सॉफ्टवेयर काइंड ऑफ
सॉफ्टवेयर टूल है ये तो आप इसको विंडोज के
लिए आप इसको या जैसे भी जो भी है मैक
वगैरह
जहां भी यूज करना चाहे आप इसको यूज कर
सकते हैं चलिए तो यहां पर ऑनलाइन अवेलेबल
है अब मैं क्या करता हूं ना व्ट आई विल डू
मैं क्या करूंगा देखिए मैं यहां पे
ना इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं यहां पे
मैं यहां पर कोई इमेज अपलोड करूंगा ठीक है
कोई भी एक इमेज अपलोड करूंगा और इसका आपको
देखता हूं कि यह क्या हमें इंफॉर्मेशन
देता है जैसे ये टूल है यहां पर मैंने एक
इमेज यहां पर क्लिक किया मैं य प कोई सा
भी एक इमेज अपलोड करके करने की कोशिश करता
हूं जैसे कि
कोई भी एक सिंपल सा चलो कोई सा भी एक इमेज
ये वाली इमेज ही मैं करता हूं ठीक है ये
वाली इमेज मैंने अपलोड कि यहां
पे अब यहां पे सक्सेस हो गया उसके बाद
यहां पे कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन आपकी आने लगी फुल
मेटा डाटा फॉर योर इमेजेस अब ये
इंफॉर्मेशन जो आ रही है इसमें क्या आ रहा
है यह तो खैर इसका वर्जन आ रहा है ठीक है
साइज आ रही है इसकी मॉडिफिकेशन जो डेट है
वो इसका इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे शो हो रहा है
उसके बाद यहां पे फाइल की टाइप आ रही है
इमेज की परमिशन क्या है तो आरडब्लू आरआर
आड यानी कि रीड राइट की परमिशन है यहां पे
अ यूजर को ग्रुप को कोई परमिशन रीड की है
ओनली अदर को भी रीड की है बस
दैट्ची यहां पे आ रहे है वो है ठीक है
उसके बाद यहां पे आ रहा है आपका कि इसका
टाइटल क्या है यह कब क्रिएट किया गया था
बेसिकली या कब मतलब इसमें कोई मॉडिफिकेशन
या कुछ आई हुई है यहां पे वो सारी चीज
यहां पे एंड क्रिएटर टूल कौन सा यूज हुआ
था तो ये कैनवा आपको दिखा रहा है कि कैनवा
से ये बनी हुई है तो अच्छी बात है इमेज की
साइज वगैरह और मेगापिक्सल जो है यहां पे
दिख रहा है तो यहां पे हमको बहुत लिमिटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है ठीक है बहुत लिमिटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है इस टूल के बारे में बट
अगर हम एक कोई ऐसी इमेज जिसका मेटा डाटा
स्ट्रिप्ट ऑफ ना हुआ हो अब ये लिमिटेड
नॉलेज हम इसलिए मिली है ना क्योंकि ये जो
इमेज है इसकी मेटा डेटा ऑलरेडी स्ट्रिप्ड
ऑफ है क्योंकि कैनवा जैसी जो वेबसाइट्स
होती हैं कैनवा जैसी जो साइट्स होती हैं
दे आर नॉट वल्नरेबल टू दिस काइंड ऑफ वनबिल
क्योंकि वो इतने सिंपल से वलने बिलिटी से
ओबवियसली इफेक्टेड नहीं होंगे ऑलरेडी वो
शॉर्ट आउट कर चुके होते हैं उसको करेक्ट
कर चुके होते हैं ठीक है वो फिक्स कर चुके
होते हैं तो इसलिए हमें बहुत ही लिमिटेड
नॉलेज मिला इस इसका बहुत ही लिमिटेड वो
मिला अब मैं यहां पे ना क्या करता हूं एक
ऐसी इमेज का डाटा मैं आपको दिखाता हूं जो
मेरे ही फोन से क्लिक किया हुआ इमेज है
ठीक है मेरे
ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेना ज्यादा तेज नहीं
बनना है आप लोगों को तो यहां पे मैंने
मेरी एक इमेज यहां पे अपलोड करी थी और कौन
सी इमेज है मैं आपको वो भी दिखा देता हूं
मैं यहां पे डाउनलोड्स में चल देता हूं और
मैंने इस वाली इमेज की ना कहां गई यह वाली
इमेज हां मेरी यह वाली जो इमेज है ये वाली
इमेज तो मैंने इस इमेज का एग्जिब डाटा
निकाला हुआ था ये जो पर्टिकुलर इमेज है
im4 264 जपजी का ठीक है तो इसका मैंने
एजिप डाटा निकाला और यह डाटा मैं आपके
सामने यहां पे दिखा रहा हूं ठीक है तो
यहां पे आप को दिखेगा मैं आपको नीचे में
इसका वो भी दिखा देता हूं फाइल का ताकि
आपको क्लियर हो
जाए आ जाओ भाई आ जाओ आ जाओ आ जाओ कहां गए
भाई चलो स्टार्टिंग से ही देखते हैं पहले
तो यहां पे आपको देखा मेरे ये फोन का ही
एक लिड है यहां पे क्या बात है यार 112
आज तो यार मजे आ गया सबको
apple.tv सीआर पोजिशनिंग जो सिस्टम्स होती
है वो है एक्सपोजर टाइम यहां पे दिया हुआ
है फोकस एम नंबर फोकस नंबर जो है वो दिया
हुआ है एक्सपोजर में प्रोग्राम ए यूज़
किया गया है आईओ 125 यूज़ किया है एग्जिट
वर्जन यहां पे दिया गया है अब देखो यहां
पे डेट टाइम ओरिजिनल ये जो है ना ओरिजिनल
डेट टाइम है ओरिजिनल कब की ये डेट टाइम है
भैया 14 सिक्स मंथ का है ठीक है यानी कि
ये 14 जून की ओरिजिनल क्लिक्ड फोटो है
टाइम थी 3:7 पे ठीक है ये क्लिक फोटो है
चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां पे क्रिएट डेट वही
बा वही बात है 14 जून के 3752 के आसपास का
वही क्रिएट डेट हो गया इसका ये इंफॉर्मेशन
हमें मिली सटर स्पीड वगैरह इन सब से हमें
कोई ज्यादा मतलब नहीं है 122 लोग हाय हाय
क्या बात है भाई रिकॉर्ड बना रहे हो तुम
लोग 122
122 अब इसमें सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग जो
इंफॉर्मेशन है वो मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा अभी
अभी तो फिलहाल नॉर्मल सी इंफॉर्मेशन है
फोकल लेंथ वगैरह यहां पे दी गई है यहां पे
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन है सेंसिंग मेथड यहां पे
वन चिप कलर एरिया यहां पे दिख रही है सीन
टाइप यहां पे डायरेक्टली फोटोग्राफ्ड यहां
पे आ रहा है एक्सपोजर मोड ऑटो वगैरह सब
ऑटो मोड में है लेंस इंफो यहां पे apple's
मेकर कौन सा है भैया तो apple's मेकर है
एंड लिया कैसे गया
iphone.com एंड f फोकस जो है अ आपका 2.2
का यहां पे सेट किया गया है इसके बाद यहां
पे अब देखो यहां पे अब यहां पे आपको समझने
वाली चीज है जो बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है
ये हालांकि मैंने इसमें चेंजेज किए हैं बट
आप समझ लीजिए जीपीएस लटटू रेफरेंस नॉर्थ
का है जीपीएस लोंगिट्यूड रेफरेंस ईस्ट का
है समझ में आ रहा है न नॉर्थ ईस्ट पहली
बात नॉर्थ एंड ईस्ट यह दो लटटू लोंगिट्यूड
सेट हो चुके हैं यहां पे एव सी लेवल यहां
पे आ रहा है स्पीड जीपीएस स्पीड का यहां
पे आ रहा है यहां पे स्पीड में कुछ नहीं आ
रही है यहां पे ट्रू नॉर्थ यहां पे आ रहा
है इमेज डायरेक्शन जो होती है ट्रू नॉर्थ
की इमेज डायरेक्शन की यहां पे
एग्जैक्ट जो है वो बताई गई है डायरेक्शन
का यहां पे ट्रू नॉर्थ यहां पे जो भी है
एंड डेस्टिनेशन बेयरिंग यहां पे बताया गया
है हॉरिजॉन्टल पोजिशनिंग यहां पे बताई गई
है चलिए इसके बाद मेन चीज अभी आना अभी और
भी आना बचा हु है यहां पे एक्सलरेटर
वेक्टर वगैरह दिया हुआ है अब यहां
पे यहां पे बात करते हैं प्रोफाइल की
डिटेल्स के बारे में तो एल कंप्यूटर आई
एनसी यहां पे वर्जन 4.0 डिस्प्ले डिवाइस
प्रोफाइल आरजीबी एक्सवाई जड व्हाट एवर एल
कंप्यूटर्स नॉट इंबेडेड एल कंप्यूटर आईसी
ठीक है अब यहां पे देखो यहां पे डिवाइस
एटिबल रिफ्लेक्टिव ग्लॉस ये ठीक है अच्छी
बात है एल कंप्यूटर यहां पे प्रोफाइल आईडी
यहां पे आपको यहां पे कुछ-कुछ प्रोफाइल
आईडी यहां पे मिल रही है कोई बात नहीं
यहां पे प्रोफाइल आईडी यहां पे रहने देते
हैं अ यह आपको पता है यहां से ऐसे उठाओगे
अरे भाई प्रोफाइल आईडी हो गई डिस्प्ले p3
कॉपीराइट एल आईसी हां यहां पे बाइनरी डाटा
में कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे आपको मिलेगी
अब यहां पे रन टाइम यहां पे कंपोजिट पावर
अप यहां पे मिल रही है कि भाई रन टाइम कब
से क्या है वो सारी चीजें मिल रही है यहां
पे क्रिएट डेट यहां पे आपको अगेन यहां पे
मिल रहा है अब यहां पे आ रहा है जीपीएस
एल्टीट्यूड जीपीएस लटटू एंड जीपीएस
लोंगिट्यूड यह आपका एग्जैक्ट जो एड्रेस
होता है ना प्रिसा इज लोकेशन यानी कि
एगजैक्टली मैं क कहां पे हूं यानी कि कहां
पे था जब यह फोटो मैंने क्लिक करी
एग्जैक्ट एड्रेस यह एग्जैक्ट आपको एड्रेस
यानी कि लोकेशन आपको यह दे रहा है और यह
लोकेशन जब आप
googleapis.com डोंट नो माइसेल्फ तो यहां
पे मैंने नंबर्स को बहुत ज्यादा जंबल कर
दिया है तो यह 98
° ठीक है 98 ° 44 अ जो है यहां पे 43.2
27° नॉर्थ यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां
पे ठीक
है
सॉरी 41 ड ईस्ट दिख रहा है तो नॉर्थ ईस्ट
ये मैंने सेम रखने दिया आपको क्योंकि
मैंने आपको पहले ही बताया था ऊपर में जो
नॉर्थ ईस्ट का जो सिनेरियो था वहां पे
दिया हुआ था तो यहां पे आपको लोंगिट्यूड
लाटीट्यूड यहां पे 98 ° 56 डिग्री यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा है यहां पे तो ये इंफॉर्मेशन
दी हुई है अब ये जो इंफॉर्मेशन होती है वो
एग्जैक्ट आपकी लोकेशन होती है एग्जैक्ट
लोकेशन ठीक है ये एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन होती है
अब इसको देख के आपका
अपना साइबर इन्वेस्टिगेशन वाला दिमाग कुछ
निकल के आ रहा है क्या इसको देख के
बताइए कुछ एक्स्ट्रा दिमाग में निकल के आ
रहा है क्या इसको देख के कि इसका यूज हम
किसी साइबर क्रिमिनल या किसी को पकड़ने के
लिए कर सकते हैं समझ में आ रहा है किसी
साइबर क्रिमिनल को पकड़ने के लिए कर सकते
हैं कोई एक ऐसी वेबसाइट पे उससे कोई ऐसी
इमेज अपलोड करवा देना जो उसके फोन से
क्लिक करी गई है एंड ये होप करना कि उसके
फोन में आपके लोकेशन का एक्सेस है जो कि
बाय डिफॉल्ट ना कैमरा में लोकेशन का
एक्सेस मिला होता है बाय डिफॉल्ट कैमरा को
लोकेशन का एक्सेस होता है बाय डिफॉल्ट
होता है मोस्टली फोन में होता है तो अगर
आपने किसी ऐसे साइबर क्रिमिनल या कोई ऐसा
क्रिमिनल है जिसको एक ऐसी वेबसाइट पे जहां
पे ये लेबिलिटी है एजिप डेटा को स्ट्रिप
नाना करने का वहां पे कोई एक इमेज अपलोड
करवा दी कुछ भी करके कैसा भी इमेज जो उसके
फोन से क्लिक्ड है तो आप उसका एग्जैक्ट
लोकेशन निकाल सकते हैं यू कैन जस्ट ट्रैक
एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन ऑफ दैट पर्सन एंड ये कुछ
तरीके हैं जो साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
में भी यूज किए जाते हैं बाय
इन्वेस्टिगेटर्स जो साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेटर्स होते हैं इनका यूज किया
जाता है पुलिस डिपार्टमेंट भी इसको यूज
करती है अपने इन्वेस्टिगेशन में इस तरीके
को यूज किया जाता है ठीक है तो ये एक
तरीका है जस्ट जस्ट अ वे मैं ये नहीं बोल
रहा कि आपको यह बग बाउंट में आपको यह चीज
करनी है बग बाउंट में तो इसका अलग चीज है
इसका अलग है कि आपको अगर जीपीएस लटटू
लोंगिट्यूड आपको जिओ लोकेशन मिल गया तो
वहां पर आपको बाउंट पक्की है आपको जिओ
लोकेशन मिल गया ना किसी इमेज के अंदर किसी
वेबसाइट के अंदर तो आपका वहां प बाउंट
पक्का है बग पक्का एक्सेप्ट होने वाला है
और आप उसको वहां पर जाके रिपोर्ट कर सकते
हैं आराम
से ठीक है गॉट इट
चलिए अब इनको एक बार ना googleapis.com
मतलब यह कोई रियल वो नहीं है तो यहां पर
कुछ आपको रियल यहां पर आपको डालना पड़ेगा
यहां पर यह कुछ लाइक लाइक ये रियल वो नहीं
है ठीक है दिस इज नॉट अ रियल डाटा रियल
लोंगिट्यूड लाटीट्यूड इसमें बहुत सारी
चेंजेज है तो रियल लोंगिट्यूड लाटीट्यूड
जब आप यूज करेंगे ग मैप्स प तो आपको उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन जो है वो आ जाएगी ठीक है अब
कुछ लोग यहां प स्पैम कर रहे हैं उनको
जल्दी से हटा देते हैं यहां से सेशन
से जल्दी से पुट यूजर इन टाइम आउट करके
एंड इनको 24 घंटे के लिए टाइम आउट करके
इनको भगा देते हैं अ ऋषु राज बहुत ज्यादा
इन्होंने मैसेज कर दिया ऋषु राज इनको भी
टाइम आउट पे कर देते
हैं फिर बाद में आप आ सकते हैं बाद में आप
आ सकते हैं रे सुराज कोई बात नहीं है जस्ट
आपने किया है वो इसलिए वो किया
है थैंक यू चलिए बढ़िया आयुष मिश्रा
वेलकम वेलकम आयुष चलिए तो ठीक है तो यहां
पे ये लोंगिट्यूड लाटीट्यूड ये वाली चीज
जो है आपकी अगर आप कहीं पे भी फोटो कहीं
पे भी कुछ अपलोड कर रहे हैं किसी अ
वेबसाइट पे तो उसका ये कर्तव्य ये धर्म
होना चाहिए कि आपकी वो जिओ लोकेशन डाटा या
एग्जिब डाटा को वो स्ट्रिप करके हटा के
एंड देन वो अपने डेटाबेस में स्टोर करके
रखे उस फोटो को एंड जब फोटो को कोई
डाउनलोड भी करता है तो वहां से आपकी डाटा
को वो ना एक्सट्रैक्ट कर पाए दैट्ची है बट
हम इसको लाइव हंट भी करके देखेंगे हम लाइव
हंटिंग आज करने वाले हैं भैया लाइव लाइव
लाइव लाइव हंटिंग करके हम ट्राई करेंगे
देखते हैं कहीं कुछ मिलता है क्या होता है
बकट पेही चल लेते हैं बकट पे ही आज हम बकट
पे ही ट्राई कर लो या ओपन बग बांटी प भी
लाइक ओपन ओपन बग बाउटी प भी ट्राई कर सकते
हो ओपन बग बाओजी प भी ट्राई कर सकते हो
ठीक है यू कैन ट्राई ऑन एनी वन तो इसमें
हम चलते हैं इंगेजमेंट्स
पे इंगेजमेंट्स प चलते हैं यहां पे है ना
ब कॉमर्स तो बी कॉमर्स में क्या है इनकी
इनकी वेबसाइट प अकाउंट क्रिएट करने का
ऑप्शन है क्या कुछ ऐसा
बिल्कुल देख सकते हो मेमोरी स्टार्क
बिल्कुल देख सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
ये देखो p3 के लिए 50 से 00 देते हैं ये
सोच रहे हो 50 से 00 दे रही है तो bom.com
यहां पे वेबसाइट है इनकी आई होप कि यहां
पर कुछ अकाउंट क्रिएशन वगैरह का कुछ हो आई
थिंक आई थिंक शायद होगी या नहीं भी होगी
पता
नहीं साइन अप साइन अप का ऑप्शन है यहां पे
अच्छी बात है साइन अप का ऑप्शन है यहां पे
ट्स गुड बट
अच्छा यह स्टोर बनाने का चलिए तो मैं य पर
स्टोर बना लेता हूं
नितेश चलिए यहां से ट्रायल स्टार्ट करने
के लिए बोल रहे हैं तो आई डोंट यह बस यह
बस क्रेडिट कार्ड ना मांगे अरवाज मैं इस
पर करना बंद कर दूंगा लेटस
स्टार्ट चलिए तो यहां पर डालते हैं
नितेश संग फोन नंबर
प्लस 91 लगाना पड़ेगा आई
थिंक ईमेल एड्रेस डाल देते हैं सो ल ड
ईमेल
आईडी टप मेल ईमेल आईडी डालते य पे देखते
हैं वल्नरेबल है कि नहीं
है हालाकि यह प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम जब लंच
होते हैं तो उनमें मोस्टली निकाल दिए जाते
हैं इन सब लेबिलिटी को तो थोड़ी मुश्किल
है बट ठीक है
ब ठीक है चलेगा देखते
हैं ओके स्टोर नेम स्टोर नेम दे देते हैं
टेस्ट स्टोर व्ट ऑनलाइन साइ बिजनेस अरे
अभी तो कुछ नहीं है नॉर्थ अमेरिका नॉर्थ
अमेरिका एशिया पैसिफिक में है
भैया एंड स्टेयर्स में एक दो तीन चर बहुत
सारे स्टेयर्स है भाई हो गया चलिए क्रिएट
योर क्रिएट योर स्टोर
रर एरर र्ड तो यह ईमेल आईडी के कारण मेरे
ख्याल से हु
होगा चलिए तो ईमेल आईडी हम रियल ईमेल आईडी
डाल देते हैं
टीम
gmail.com ठीक
है चलिए य पर पासवर्ड दे लिया यहां पर
स्टोर नेम दे देते हैं माय स्टोर ऑनलाइन
बिजनेस अभी तो स्टार्ट किया है एशिया
पैसिफिक डाल देते हैं यहां पर अगेन कर
लेते हैं ट्रैक्टर्स ले लेते हैं एक दोती
चार चार डक्टस यहां पर क्रिएट योर स्टोर
लेट्स सी हां तो ईमेल आईडी के कारण था
टेंप मेल को यह एक्सेप्ट नहीं कर रहे थे
ट्स वाई वी गट द एरर य हमने रियल ईमेल
आईडी डाली तो हमारा यहां पर काम हो चुका
है ठीक
है चलिए अब देखते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इ
हैपनिंग ी रेडी इन वन मिनट
सर आपके पढ़ने का मजा लग क्या बात है भाई
चलो अच्छी बात है यार आप लोग 100 प्लस आ
रहे हो ना बस मजे आ रहे है फिर इसी में
एकदम शानदार वाले
मजे ऐसे ही आते रहो फिर खतरनाक कंटेंट और
आएगी तुम सोचो ना यार ई पीटी एंड
प्रैक्टिकल लेवल की ट्रेनिंग फ्री में
आपको हम देने वाले हैं सोचो हमारा उसमें
बस एक ही फायदा होता है कि
youtube2 या तीन महीने प कुछ पैसे आएंगे
बाकी हम आपको दे रहे हैं डेली हम आपको
क्वालिटी कंटेंट दे रहे हैं ठीक है
क्वालिटी कंटेंट से मैटर रखिएगा आप लोग बस
ट्स इट उससे ज्यादा कुछ
नहीं हो गया बिग कॉमर्स स्टोर अरे भाई हो
गया यार नो नहीं है व्हाट विल बी सेलिंग
डिजिटल गुड्स एंड सॉफ्टवेयर्स डिस्क आई एम
सेलिंग मेलिन पर्सन डिटेल थ ऑनलाइन
मार्केट प्लेस प्रोसीड टू स्टोर आई होप कि
यहां पे कुछ इमेजेस वगैरह अपलोड करने का
ऑप्शन
हो हां जी तो हम अपने स्टोर पे आ चुके
हैं चलिए हम अपने स्टोर पे आ चुके हैं
अच्छी बात है यहां पे ऐड प्रोडक्ट्स यहां
पे गेट इन टू स्लिप जो भी है यहां पे अब
यहां पे हम अपनी कोई प्रोफाइल वगैरह पे
देखते हैं कोई प्रोफाइल वगैरह पे माय
प्रोफाइल पे चलते हैं प्रोफाइल इंफॉर्मेशन
पे चलते हैं आई होप कि यहां पे इमेज अपलोड
करने का कोई ऑप्शन हो इनके पास अरे ऑप्शन
ही नहीं है हद है यार ये क्या सी बात हो
गई अ प्रोफाइल ईमेल एड्रेस पे तो ईमेल
एड्रेस आएगा पासवर्ड आएगा तो चलो एक काम
करते हैं कोई और वाले प चलते
हैं प्रोडक्ट्स पे चलते हैं प्रोडक्ट्स पे
प्रोडक्ट्स करते हैं ठीक है ना प्रोडक्ट प
करते हैं कुछ लोगों को फिर से भगाते हैं
यहां से क्या है भागने के
लिए मैंने बोला ना स्पैम करोगे तो ना तो
रिप्लाई मिलेगा ना
ही कुछ होगा तो भगा दिया आपको
तो यहां पर प्रोडक्ट आ चुके य पर कुछ
सैंपल प्रोडक्ट यहां पर दिए गए हैं य ठीक
है सैंपल प्रोडक्ट है काफी अच्छी बात है
यहां पर हम एक ऐड प्रोडक्ट पर क्लिक करते
हैं एक कोई सा भी एक ड प्रोडक्ट करते हैं
यहां पर
एंड इमेजेस डालने के है ना यहां पर हा जी
इमेजेस यहां पर है बहुत बढ़िया इमेज यहां
पर है तो मैं य पर प्रोडक्ट नेम डाल देता
हूं टेस्ट प्रोडक्ट एस केयू डाल देता हूं
टेस्ट टूथ प्रोडक्ट टाइप डिजिटल है
प्राइसिंग इज 00 का इमेज है हमारा ब्रांड
हमारा है डि फ्रॉक्स ब्रांड डि फ्रॉक्स
ब्रांड है हमारा उसके बाद यहां पर कैटेगरी
क्या है किचन नहीं यार किचन थोड़ी ना है
चलो शॉप ल में आ जाते हैं इमेज में दिस इज
अ टेस्ट
प्रोडक्ट डाल देते हैं यहां पे हम अपलोड
इमेज करते हैं अब देखो जो मैं अपलोड इमेज
कर रहा हूं तो मैं ना यहां पे एक इमेज
यहां पे मैं कोई टेस्ट इमेज यहां पे कोई
एक टेस्ट इमेज ले लेंगे ठीक है कोई भी एक
टेस्ट इमेज ले लेंगे जो हमें अपलोड करना
है तो हम पहले उसको देख लेंगे कि भैया वो
एक्चुअली वल्नरेबल है उससे एग्जिट डटा
उसके अंदर क्या है क्या नहीं है ये हम
पहले ही देख लेंगे पहले ही हम क्लियर कर
लेंगे ठीक है तो चलिए हम कोई सा भी एक
इमेज ले लेते हैं जैसे कि मैंने यहां पे
एक इमेज डाली हुई थी यहां पे कोई और एक
इमेज डाल के और वहां पे अपलोड करके
देखेंगे कि उसमें कोई एग्जिब डाटा रहती है
कि नहीं अब मेरी जो इमेज है ना मेरी जो
इमेज वो उसमें एग्जिब डाटा है मेरी जो
इमेज थी उसमें एग्जिब डाटा थी ठीक है तो
चलिए मैं क्या करता हूं मैं यहां पे अपलोड
इमेज करता हूं ए मेरी ही इमेज अपलोड कर
देता हूं जिस एजिप डाटा थी मेरी वाली जो
इमेज थी यह वाली आईजी 4264 है इसमें इसमें
एक्चुअली एजिप डाटा एजिप डाटा पूरी डिटेल
यहां पे आ रही थी तो अब मैं देखता हूं कि
ये लोग क्या करते हैं इस इमेज के साथ ठीक
है राइट अ डिस्क्रिप्शन माय इमेज कुछ भी
डाल देते हैं ठीक है
दैट्ची है प्रोडक्ट वेरिएशन ठीक है ज्यादा
कुछ डालना नहीं है सेव पे क्लिक करते हैं
देखते हैं सेव होता कि नहीं या कोई डिटेल
और भी चाहिए
इनको लोडिंग योर प्रोडक्ट चलिए प्रोडक्ट्स
सेव्ड सक्सेसफुली क्या बात है यार
प्रोडक्ट सेव हो चुका है यहां पे तो अब
मैं व्यू प्रोडक्ट प चलता हूं यहां पे
प्रोडक्ट को व्यू करते हैं भैया यह रहा
टेस्ट प्रोडक्ट टेस्ट प्रोडक्ट को ओपन कर
लेते हैं न्यू टैब में यहां पे अच्छी बात
है यहां पे लेट्स लेट्स ओपन इट व्यू ऑन
स्टोर फ्रंट स्टोर फ्रंट पर चलते हैं एंड
देखते हैं ये प्रोडक्ट
को एक प्रोडक्ट हमने बनाया टेस्ट प्रोडक्ट
प्रोडक्ट तो हमने टेक्स्ट प्रोडक्ट बनाया
और ये इमेज हमारी आ चुकी है अब इस इमेज को
हम एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करते हैं ओपन इ
इमेज इन न्यू टैब तो आप देख सकते हैं कि
सीडीएन में इस इमेज ये इमेज जो है इनके
सीडीएन वाली लिंक प जो है यह स्टोर हो
चुकी है यहां पे इनका सीडीएन जो है यहां
पे ये हैर और इसको मैं कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल
सी कॉपी करके एंड मैं इसको न्यू टैब में
ओपन करता हूं यहां पे तो इमेज हमारी ओपन
हो रही है तो डॉट जेपीजी जो है इसको हम
ओपन कर लेते हैं ठीक है जी हां तो ये ओपन
हो गई अब हम क्या करते है ना इसको हम अपने
चेक करते हैं एजिप टूल में ठीक है तो यहां
पे बेसिकली यह तो फाइल अपलोड का यहां पे
ऑप्शन है यहां पे लिंक का यहां पे कुछ सीन
यहां पे तो है नहीं है ना लिंक का सीन
नहीं है तो लिंक वाली इस पे चल जाते हैं य
एनालाइज अ यूआरएल यहां पे एंड यहां पे डाल
देते हैं ये एंड इंस्पेक्ट यूआरएल
इंस्पेक्ट यूआरएल पे करते हैं और देखते
हैं फिर हमें क्या इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है तो
यहां पे हमें कुछ डिटेल्स मिली यहां पे
एंड यहां पे जब आप डिटेल पी डिटेल को आउट
कर रहे हैं गाइस तो यहां पे लोकेशन की कोई
डिटेल हमें यहां पे नहीं मिली है देखो अभी
ये सेम इमेज सेम इमेज
मैंने जब डायरेक्ट इसको चेक किया था
डायरेक्ट इसको चेक किया था तो मुझे पूरी
की पूरी लोकेशन की डिटेल भी यहां पे मिल
रही थी पूरी की पूरी इस फाइल की लोकेशन की
डिटेल मिल रही थी ओके तो यहां पे अभी
लोकेशन की डिटेल आपकी नहीं आ रही है चलिए
अब यहां से एक और एग्जिट टूल है यहां पे
भी हम इसको देख लेते हैं है ना यहां प
अपलोड करते हैं यूआरएल से
अपलोड आ गई यहां पे ये इमेज आ गई आपकी
यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आते हैं यहां पे एंड
यह देखिए लोकेशन में क्या आ रहा है दिस
फोटो डज नॉट इंक्लूड लोकेशन डाटा वी कैन
नॉट फाइंड वयर इट वाज टेकन यानी कि यहां
पे क्या हुआ है अब मुझे आप बताइए यहां पे
सेम इमेज की यहां पे मुझे लोकेशन ऑलरेडी
मिली थी जीपीएस लटटू लोंगिट्यूड ये उसी
इमेज की है जो मैंने
iphone11 जब मैंने साइट पे अपलोड नहीं की
डायरेक्टली अपने पीसी से इसका लो एग्जिट
डाटा निकाला तो मेरे को लोंगिट्यूड
लाटीट्यूड सब कुछ मिला बट यहां पे जब
मैंने इस वेबसाइट पे जब मैं इस पे बग
बाउंट कर रहा हूं मेरा टारगेट कौन सी
वेबसाइट है मेरा टारगेट एक बग क्राउड का
एक अ एक कंपनी है बिग कॉमर्स करके इस पे
मैं ट्राई कर रहा हूं कि भैया इसमें ये
लेबिलिटी है कि नहीं है तो मैंने इनके पास
प्रोफाइल बनाया एक स्टोर टैब एक स्टोर अ
स्टोर फ्रंट बनाया मैंने एक प्रोडक्ट ऐड
किया एंड वहां पे इमेज ऐड किया अब मैं इस
इमेज की जब इंफो निकालने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं तो एफ टूल या डाटा में मेरे को लोकेशन
यहां पे कहीं पे भी नहीं मिल रही है यहां
पे भी मैंने जब लोकेशन देखा यहां पे आ रहा
है नो नो लोकेशन इसका मतलब क्या हुआ इसका
मतलब यह हुआ कि आपके इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट
पे जब आपने इस इमेज को अपलोड किया तो इसने
आपके एफ उस मेटा डटा को जिओ लोकेशन वाली
मेटा डाटा को वहां से स्ट्रिप कर दिया हटा
दिया आपके इमेज से आपकी सिक्योरिटी के
परपस से ताकि आपका जो प्राइवेसी है वो
ब्रीच ना हो पाए आपकी प्राइवेट इंफॉर्मेशन
आपकी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
किसी और तक ना पहुंच पाए तो उसने हटा दिया
यानी कि यह वेबसाइट फुली सिक्योर है फ्रॉम
दिस पर्टिकुलर वनबिल समझ में आ रहा है
वेबसाइट इज सैनिटाइजिंग द इमेज बोल लो या
वेबसाइट इज सिंपली क्या कर रहा है
स्ट्रिपिंग द सिंपल जो स्ट्रिप कर रहा है
स्ट्रिपिंग द एजि डाटा जो आपका डटा है
मेटा डाटा है उसको उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन को ये
हटा रहा है उस इमेज से निकाल के फेंक दे
रहा है बाहर एंड तब जाके आपको ये
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको जो ये इमेज है मिल रही है
स्ट्रिप्ट इमेज की स्ट्रिप्ट डाटा के साथ
मिल रही है ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है तो
इसका मतलब यह वल्नरेबल नहीं है यह वाली जो
हमारी पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट है हमारी भैया यह
वल्नरेबल नहीं है गॉट
इट गॉट इट सभी को समझ में आ गया यह
वल्नरेबल नहीं है समझ में आ गया सबको यह
बता
दीजिए आप भी अपनी डाटा हटा सकते हो यार
इमेज मेटा डाटा हटा सकते हो आप अपने डाटा
व हटा सकते हो एफ एफ डाटा रिमूवर पे आप
जाइए यहां पे कोई सा भी मेटा डाटा हटाना
हो बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस आते हैं आपको आपको
मिल जाएंगे यहां पे जाइए यहां पे जो भी
इमेज डालना है डाल दीजिए एंड यहां पे क्या
करना है यहां पे ये देखिए इमेज
डालिए यहां पे अपलोड फोटो डाउनलोड
क्लीयर्ड फोटो तो ये क्या करेगा इमेज को
हटा देगा रिमूव एजिप पे आप आ गए हैं यहां
पे इमेज डाल दीजिए एंड आपको ये रिमूव करके
आपका एजिप डाटा जो है रिमूव करके निकाल के
दे देगा सिंपल सा ठीक है अब यहां पे ड्रॉप
अ फाइल हियर टू मेटा डाटा यहां पे अ यहां
पे भी सेम चीज है यहां पे आप इससे डाल
दीजिए या यूआरएल वाली चीज है तो यूआरएल से
कर दीजिए तो हमने यूआरएल वाली बेसिकली देख
ली थी
यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं य रिमूव ऑ कर
सकते हैं य ठीक है एंड यहां पर एफ पर चल
देते हैं
ए र
ि क्लोज कर देता हूं
मैं य व्यू और रिमूव एप डाटा है यहां पर
तो व्यू एजिप प हम करते हैं य प तो मैं य
पर अगेन फिर से यहां पर लिंक डाल देता हूं
व्यू एप प क्लिक करता हूं देखते
हैं ठीक है तो ए डटा में यह इंफॉर्मेशन आई
छोटी इंफॉर्मेशन है यहां पे एंड दैट्ची
मतलब यहां पे यह तो इमेज रिमूव का है ना
रिमूव का है इसको हटा दो अ यहां चलते हैं
यहां चलते हैं इमेज मेटा
डाटा z simple.com आ गए यहां चलते हैं z
simple.com पे इमेज यहां पे डालते हैं हम
अपनी इमेज यहां पे डालते हैं यह वाली
इमेज एंड यू विल गेट द डिटेल्स यहां पे
आपको डिटेल्स यहां पे दिख रही है यहां पे
बहुत सारी डिटेल्स यहां पे आ रही है यह
देखो यहां पे लोकेशन आ रहा है ना यहां पे
लोकेशन आना शुरू हो चुका है ठीक है तो यह
लोकेशन आपको यहां पे प्रोवाइड कर देगा ठीक
है तो दैट्ची थिंग जो आप यहां पे यहां पे
लोकेशन मिल रही है बट यहां पे वेबसाइट प
अपलोड करके इसका मतलब ये वेबसाइट वल्नरेबल
नहीं है दिस वेबसाइट इज नॉट वल्नरेबल ट्स
इट बस इतना ही आपको समझना है चलिए अब यहां
पे चलते हैं कोई और हमारी एक टारगेट पे
कोई ऐसी टारगेट जो इमेज अपलोड का प्रोफाइल
के अंदर में फंक्शनैलिटी प्रोवाइड करता हो
हमें उससे मतलब है जो इमेज अपलोड का
फंक्शनैलिटी प्रोवाइड करता हो ट्स इट कोई
वेबसाइट आप बताइए टारगेट
बताइए यस यस
रिमूव कर देते हैं बिल्कुल
आई थिंक इसमें अपलोड इमेज अपलोड करने का
ऑप्शन नहीं आता मशो में आई थिंक जहां तक
मुझे मुझे लगता है तो इसमें शायद य
एलिजिबल नहीं
होगा तोड़ फोड़ हो जा
बताइए मुझे बताइए मुझे बताइए कौन सी अरे
स्प चट वग रिमूव कर देती है यार स्प चट
रिमूव कर देती है चलो मैं अपने से लेता
हूं कोई कोई एक टारगेट ले लेता हूं कोई एक
टारगेट ले लेता हूं लेट्स
लेट्स गो फॉर टारगेट पहले मैं इसको क्लोज
कर देता हूं फालतू का वो ले रहा
है मैं ना यहां पर ना इसको फिल्टर आउट
करता हूं डेट्स के डेट्स के हिसाब से
फिल्टर आउट करे क्या टारगेट कैटेगरी को
करे क्या नहीं डेट्स के हिसाब से टारगेट
कैटेगरी में वेप कर लेते हैं पहले तो
अप्लाई कर देते हैं उसके बाद ना डेट्स में
पुरानी डेट से करते हैं यार स्टार्ट डेट
या एंड डेट चलो स्टार्ट डेट ना थोड़ा पहले
का कर लेते हैं 24 से नहीं करते
हैं
2000 20 का कोई प्रोग्राम उठाते
हैं ठीक है अप्लाई कर देते
हैं स्टार्ट डेट से करते हैं एंड असेंडिंग
ऑर्डर में करते हैं ताकि पहले वाले हमारे
को मिल जाए ठीक है तो पुराने कोई सा भी
उठा लेते हैं अ
लाइ ये कुछ ज्यादा
ही आगे का डेट दिया मैंने 2020 नहीं 2019
18 और भी पहले करता 15 कर लेते
15 जनवरी अप्लाई कर देते हैं लेट्स सी हा
जी तो यहां से कोई उठाते हैं टेस्ला ह
स्पॉट यो
जप कोई भी आ जाओ
भाई एक्स वाइज वाइज में होगा क्या देखते
हैं ट्रांसफर वाइज वाइज इनका ट्रांसफरवाइज
कॉ प देखते हैं क्या है क्या सीन है
इनका अच्छा रजिस्टर करने का है ना ऑप्शन
यहां पे रजिस्टर पर क्लिक करते
हैं ठीक है वाइज अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लेते
हैं एंटर योर ईमेल एड्रेस ठीक है तो मैं
यहां पर
पे ग से लॉग इन कर लेता हूं टू ठीक है ना
तो मैं टीम डि फोनिक्स वाली प ग से लॉगइन
कर लेता हूं कंटिन्यू कर लेता हूं
मैं सेंड मनी ग्लोबली या गेट पेड फ्रॉम
अब्रॉड यही कर लेते हैं वे बिजनेस लोकेटेड
इंडिया में ही है ट नंबर तो मैं नंबर दे
देता हूं
वेरिफिकेशन कोड तो मैं कोड डाल देता हूं
वेरिफिकेशन कोड जो भी
है कर दिया पासवर्ड यहां बना देते
हैं पासवर्ड डाल दिया आपने कंटिन्यू कर
देते हैं ठीक है आई होप कि यहां पर भी
अपलोड का कुछ मिले हमें व्हाट इज योर रोल
एज अ बिजनेस डायरेक्टर और सिग्निफिकेंट
शेयर होल्डर तो डायरेक्टर कर देता हूं मैं
यहां
पर अरे यार क्या नाटक है यार इंडिया में
यह इन्होंने वेट लिस्ट कर
दिया ये वेट लिस्ट कर दिया जॉइन द वेट
लिस्ट चलो ठीक है हटाओ य पागल बना दिया
इन्होने वेटलिस्ट चालू कर दिया अा ठीक है
ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं अंदर
तो ओपन हो गया ऑन बोर्डिंग में यहां पर
अगर प्रोफाइल में अपलोड करने का कुछ ऑप्शन
मिल जाए तो मजा ही आ जाए लेट्स गो
अरे भाई कुछ तो
आ य क्या है होम पर चलते हैं प्रोफाइल
अपलोड करने का तो ऑप्शन आ जा भाई इमेज
अपलोड तो कुछ तो करवाओ इमेज अपलोड या कहीं
से भी ड रिस पेंट में इमेज आएगा क्या यह
तो करेंसी का है पेमेंट्स में क्या है भाई
फिनिश अकाउंट सेटअप चलो कर लेते
हैं व टाइप अकाउंट वा टू सेड पर्सनल
पर्सनल कर लेते हैं बिजनेस वाला अभी तो
गया ब अरे यार यह बहुत नाटक है इसमें दे
दे आर नॉट गिविंग द ऑप्शन टू अपलोड
इमेज तो यहां से इसको छोड़ ही दो इमेज
अपलोड करने का ऑप्शन ही नहीं है लेट्स टेक
सम टा क्या है भाई ऑक्टा
य कौन सा सी सीक के तो काफी सारे हैं हा
सी के काफी सारे हैं सीक वाली सी को ले
लेते हैं मै स सीड कॉ इस पर कुछ है
क्या लेट सी साइन अप साइन सीक पासड कोड
अच्छा साइन इन प चलते
है गेट कोड
एंटर ईमेल टू गेट वन टाम एक्सेस
कोड
सीरियसली चलो
भाई टेंप मेल जिंदाबाद टप मेल जिंदाबाद
पता नहीं य एक्सेप्ट करते नहीं ट मेल को
नहीं करेंगे तो रियल ईमेल आईडी यूज कर
लेंगे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है क्योंकि हमें
तो यहां पर देखना ही है करके कि क्या हो
रहा
है क्या बात है यार ल में तो आराम से दे
रहे ये चलो आने दो
ओटीपी
9317 अरे यार 17 है यार
17 हमने कर दिया लॉगिन हां जी तो यहां पर
बढ़िया चीज है यह सीक पास यहां पर
प्रोफाइल में शायद अपलोड करने का ऑप्शन
हमारे पास आ
जाएगा मे
बी कुछ तो आजा भाई ऑस्ट्रेलिया कंट्री है
अरे वाह
कुछ है ही नहीं य पर भी गजब का बेकार
अच्छा एयू वाला ओपन हुआ ना हमारा एयू
वाला डिजिटल
आईडी एजुकेशनल क्वालिफिकेशन
इसमें नहीं करेंगे कुछ कुछ तो इमेज डालने
का कुछ तो होगा यार डिजिटल आईडी में वूर
आइडेंटिटी स्टार्ट वेरिफिकेशन क्या है य
यार ऑस्ट्रेलिया न्यूजीलैंड
ऑस्ट्रेलिया वाली हमने ओपन कर लिया है ना
इसलिए इसलिए ये हुआ है ठीक है कोई और ओपन
कर लेते है ना कि वा कॉ का वा कॉ तो नहीं
करेंगे यह तो हटा दिया हमने इसका हम
करेंगे जॉब एआई डट स पासड
को इसमें कुछ है नहीं हटा यहां प स्क्रीन
इंफ्रा स्क्रीन इफरा ड एक्सवा ज देखते हैं
इसम कुछ है कि नहीं कोई सिंपल सी वेबसाइट
प भी ट्राई कर लेंगे चलो हम ना नॉर्मल सी
वेबसाइट पर ट्राई करते हैं इन पे नहीं
करते हम नॉर्मल सी वेबसाइट पर ट्राई करते
हैं जैसे कि मन कॉ देखते हैं makan.com
अभी चला है कि नहीं चल रहा है कि नहीं हां
जी है यहां पे तो makan.com प चलते
हैं क्या है चैट देख नहीं रहा था यार सर
आई एम नॉट स्पैमिंग बट आई हैव अ क्वेश्चन
वेयर आई गट स्टक इन बक क्राउड सम
प्रोग्राम सेज यूज बक क्राउड ninja.com
ईमेल आईडी व्हाट डज इट मीन सर प्लीज
रिप्लाई आपका यूजर नेम आपका यूजर नेम जो
होता है वही आपका ईमेल आईडी है ब्राउंड
में यूजरनेम @ bin.com ठीक है तो आप उसको
यूज कर सकते हैं ए ईमेल आईडी समझ आया आप
लोग पढ़ते नहीं हो यार देखो यहां पर भी
कहीं लिखा होगा मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
बक्र निंजा
का बक क्राउड यह रहा यह देखो यहां पे
प्लीज साइन अप फॉर अकाउंट्स ऑन se.com एंड
talent.com एंड ऑल सीक पास एसेट्स यूजिंग
योर @b ninja.com ईमेल आईडी फॉर मोर
इंफॉर्मेशन रिगार्डिंग बक्र ईमेल एड्रेस
सी हियर ठीक है यहां पर क्लिक करते हैं आप
अगर तो आपको बहुत कुछ पता चल जाता यहां पे
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे होती है यू कैन
क्रिएट ये ये करके अब यहां पे ना इनका जो
आपका जो यूजर नेम होता है ना वही होता है
आपका ईमेल आईडी यूजरनेम @b ninja.com करके
एंड आप कर लीजिएगा ठीक है यहां पे आप देख
लीजिए यहां पे सिंपल सा @ बक्र अब यहां पे
मैं यूजर नेम इन्होने कहीं पे मेंशन यहां
पे कर रखा
होगा नहीं गया है ठीक है बक्र निंजा का
यही होता है अपना यूजर नेम वहां पे मेंशन
कीजिएगा ठीक है यूजर नेम मेंशन कीजिएगा
चलिए तो यहां पे makan.com पे आ चुके हैं
हम यहां पे लॉगिन पे क्लिक कर देते हैं
यहां पर मैं ग से लॉग इन कर लेता
हूं ठीक
है चलिए हमने लॉगइन कर दिया मैन अब य
प्रोफाइल पर चलते हैं देखते हैं अपलोड
इमेज अपलोड वगर करने का कुछ ऑप्शन है कि
नहीं है अकाउंट में कुछ है क्या य पर
प्रोफाइल में चलते हैं माय जर्नी अलोन
इंटरने लोन माय जर्नी कुछ है नहीं यार यार
कहीं तो कुछ अपलोड कुछ की प्र खुद की
प्रोफाइल बनाने का दे दो भाई मकान
कॉ माय फेवरेट सिटी टॉप बिल्डर्स लोन रियल
एस्टेट सेल या रेंट प्रोपर्टी चलो सेल या
रेंट हाउस सेल या रेंट प्रॉपर्टी फ्री चलो
सेल या रेंट प्रॉपर्टी देखते हैं य
स्टार्ट लिस्टिंग इसमें तो होता ही
होगा ओनर हूं मैं मोबाइल नंबर चाहिए क्या
आपको
चलो मोबाइल नंबर देते
हैं ओटीपी ले लेते
हैं 9419 है ना 9419
9419 एग्री कर लेते हैं लिस्ट प्रॉपर्टी
पर चलते है य ठीक है स्टार्ट लिस्टिंग अब
यहां पर ग का हैना डालने का
भाई इसमें तो होगा ड इमेजेस आ रहे य ड
इमेजेस चलिए य अच्छी बात ड इमे य पर
सेक्शन आ चुका है तो अच्छी बात है आई वांट
टू सेल मैं सेल करना चाहता हूं एंड मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं अपार्टमेंट सेल करना
चाहता हूं विला स्टूडियो क्या अपार्टमेंट
ही सेल कर देता हूं मैं वेर द अपार्टमेंट
लोकेटेड
नोएडा सिटी
नोएडा बिल्डिंग प्रोजेक्ट या सोसाइटी
पैरामाउंट लोकेलिटी 137 हो चुका है यहां
पे बढ़िया अच्छी बात है यहां पे नंबर ऑफ
बेडरूम्स थ्री बेडरूम्स है वैसे है नहीं
बट डाल देता हूं सिलेक्ट फ्लोर
प्लान थ बीएच के टू ठीक है यह वाला ऐड कर
देते हैं डन टेल अस योर प्रॉपर्टी
एरिया इतना ही रहने देते हैं जो यहां पर
ऑलरेडी है यहां पर रहने देते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
है बाकी तो कोई इंपॉर्टेंट है नहीं यहां
पे बाथरूम वगैरह ये सब है यहां पे व्हाट
इज एक्सपेक्टेड प्राइस अ
0000 अच्छा पर स्क्वायर फीट है एक ₹ पर स्
नहीं ₹1 पर स्क्वायर फीट टू लो है क्या ₹1
000 अरे भाई 000 भी टू लो है
0000 ओ माय गॉड नेगोशिएबल है ना भाई ₹
लाख टू लो फॉर दिस प्रॉपर्टी ह दे
यार अरे भाई साहब
टू हाई अभी देखो टू हाई हो गया वाह वाह
वाह मैं कर देता हूं
95000 र अच्छा 95 प्राइस पूछ रहा य तो मैं
डाल देता हूं 55 लाख चलिए 55 डाल देता हूं
मैं नेगोशिएबल है बुकिंग अमाउंट यहां
पर 5 लाख डाल देते हैं ठीक
है यहां पर बुकिंग अमाउंट देते रेडी टू
मूव इन प्रॉपर्टी ए जो है कम डालते हैं
लेस दन न ईयर ट्रांजेक्शन टाइप रिसेल कर
लेते हैं डिस्क्रिप्शन टेस्ट
बाकी नहीं डालेंगे ड इमेज अब ड इमेज में
चलते इनको इनको शौक देते हैं इमेज हमने
मेरी नहीं मेरी खुद की इमेज डाल द क्या
डाल देते क्या क्या जाता है टेस्ट तो करही
रहे क्या करते है हमारे मैं खुद फेमस हो
जाऊंगा
ना यह कौन सा यह कौन सा इमेज है भाई अदर
इमेज
हैय ठीक है बाद में इसको हटा देंगे ना अब
यहां पर मैं क्या कर देता हूं यहां पर
सॉरी यहां पर हमने इमेज डाल दी यहां पर
ओपन इमेज न देखते अपलोड हुआ कि नहींन अभी
फिलहाल के लिए अपलोड हुआ है या नहीं बेस
64 का इनकोडिंग कर रहे ये खैर कोई बात
नहीं हम यहां पर पब्लिश कर देते हैं
पब्लिश कर देते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग सो या अ स्कोर ऑफ टू योर
प्रॉपर्टी विल बी लाइव सून विथ टेंटे
स्कोर ऑफ 2.0 आउट ऑ 5 ठीक है यहां
पे सबमिट कर देते
हैं पोस्ट वेरिफिकेशन ओके इन्होंने
वेरिफिकेशन के लिए डाला हुआ है बट कोई बात
नहीं वेरिफिकेशन के लिए डाला हुआ है ना बट
हम ना इमेज का देखेंगे कि इमेज हम
इन्होंने सेव किया कि नहीं st.com जपजी
चलिए ये इन्होंने अपनी सीडीएन में सेव कर
लिया है तो हमें इसी से मतलब था अब हम
इसका यहां पे कॉपी करते हैं यहां पे जो
इमेज है इसको यहां पे पेस्ट करते हैं ओपन
करते हैं बढ़िया अब देखते हैं कि यह मेटा
डाटा का के साथ कुछ छेड़छाड़ कर रहा है कि
नहीं कर रहा है राइट लेट्स सी गाइस वेल
नाउ लेट्स सी तो यहां पर यूआरएल डालते हैं
भैया इंस्पेक्ट करते हैं लेट्स सी क्या हो
रहा
है एनालाइज करते हैं एंड यहां पे हमें कुछ
खास हां हमें यहां पे फिर से लोकेशन इंफो
नहीं मिली है यहां पे अगेन दिस इज आई थिंक
ओबवियसली यह कर रहे हैं फेच कर रहे मेटा
डाटा को रिमूव कर रही है मेटा डाटा को
चलिए अच्छी बात है मेटा डाटा को रिमूव कर
रही है दिस इज आल्सो वो लाइक मैं यहां पे
करता हूं इच पे एंड इस पे चलते हैं
और यह वाली तो हटा दो इस पे चलते हैं यहां
पे यहां पे देखते हैं डाल के इनको अपलोड
करते हैं लेट्स सी इफ दे आर रिमूविंग मेटा
डेटा और नॉट सो यहां पे आ चुकी है
इंफॉर्मेशन सारी लोकेशन की इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं आ रही यानी कि दे आर स्ट्रिपिंग ऑफ द
मेटा डाटा तो makan.com भी यही स्ट्रिप ऑफ
कर रहा है हटा रहा है भाई
दैट्ची है jio.com पे तो पॉसिबल ही नहीं
है मेरे ख्याल से शायद इनकी बॉक बाउंट
प्रोग्राम्स भी चलती है तो इसमें ज्यादा
कुछ मुझे नहीं लगता मिलने वाला है बट
स्टिल अगर आप चाहे तो बट वही है कि यहां
पर लॉगइन करना पड़ेगा मुझे तो पॉसिबल है
नहीं अभी फिलहाल के लिए तो इसको रिमूव कर
लेते हैं इसको फिलहाल के लिए हटा देते हैं
बाकी कोई और भी वेबसाइट है आप उस पर ट्राई
आउट कीजिएगा जहां भी भैया आप पहले क्या
करना मैं आपको क्लियर इसका एग्जांपल इसका
सिंपल सा तरीका बता देता हूं आप क्या
कीजिएगा पहले आप कोई एक इमेज ले लीजिएगा
ठीक है एग्जांपल इमेज भी ले सकते हैं आप
जैसे देखो ना यहां पे
एफ सैंपल
इमेजेस आपको यहां पे गिट प मिल जाएगी
सैंपल इमेजेस ठीक है एजी फॉली मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं यहां पे आप आएंगे यहां पे
तो जेपीजी चाहिए आपको तो जेपीजी प चले
जाइएगा यहां पे आपको जीपीएस वाली इमेजेस
चाहिए जीपीएस लोकेशन जिसके साथ है
प्रेजेंट है वो वाली तो आपको बहुत सारी
यहां प इमेजेस मिल जाएंगी ठीक है तो जैसे
मान लो कोई भी एक इमेज डाउनलोड कर लो ठीक
है तो मैंने ये इमेज मान लो डाउनलोड कर ली
मान लो ये वाली इमेज जो है ये डाउनलोड कर
ली या कोई और भी इमेज है इसको ओपन कर ली
ये वाली इमेज है इसको डाउनलोड कर मैंने
इसको डाउनलोड कर लिया र फाइल को डाउनलोड
कर लिया य जेपीजी अब इसको तुम पहले चेक कर
लो पहले तुम क्या चेक करोगे पहले तुम चेक
करो कि इसमें जीपीएस लोकेशन है कि नहीं है
भैया तो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर अपलोड
कर देता हूं डाउनलोड में ये मैं जो अपलोड
कर देता हूं और इसकी एजि डाटा देखता हूं
कि इसके मेटा डाटा में क्या है तो यहां
नेम है सब कुछ है यहां पे इसकी लोकेशन आ
रही है लटटू एंड लोंगिट्यूड
देखा य आराम से दिख रहा है
यहां पर सबको दे रहा है इजी व बिलिटी है
ना इजी बहुत इजी है बट पी3 कैटेगरी में
फॉल करती है भाई बकरा आउट के ऊपर बहुत इजी
है बट पी3 कैटेगरी में फॉल करती है पता है
इसका इसमें बाउंट लेने का एक तरीका मैं
आपको बताता हूं मतलब क्विक बाउंट लेने के
तरीका बताता हूं कोई भी पॉपुलर वेबसाइट पर
यह जनरली मत खोजो इस पर्टिकुलर लेबिलिटी
को इस जो यह लेबिलिटी आपकी बक क्राउड पर
है यहां पर मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
यह जो आपकी लेबिलिटी है एजि जियो लोकेशन
डाटा नॉट स्ट्रिप फ्रॉम अपलोडेड इमेज पी3
कैटेगरी में आती है तो मैं आपको एक टिप
देता हूं छोटा सा प्यारा सा टिप बड़ी
पॉपुलर वेबसाइट पर आप इसको मत चेक करो
ऑलरेडी उस परे य लेबिलिटी नहीं होगी आप
ऐसी डोमेन ऐसी प्रोग्राम को खोजो जो
डायरेक्ट अप्रोचेबल हो बक क्राउड हैकर वन
पे मुझे लगता है 90 पर 95 पर प्रोग्राम्स
में ये अवेलेबिलिटी नहीं होनी चाहिए मेरे
ख्याल से हो भी सकती है ऐसा नहीं है कि
नहीं होंगी हो भी सकती है तो आप ट्राई
करना ऐसी प्रोग्राम को खोजने का जो बहुत
पॉपुलर ना हो बहुत ज्यादा टाइम्स उस पे
हंटर्स काम ना कर रहे हो बहुत पुरानी कोई
लिस्टेड प्रोग्राम हो उसपे ट्राई आउट मारो
और उसको रिपोर्ट मारो दैट्ची ये और उसके
बाद
google3 है उस पे ट्राई आउट करो वहां पे
फाइंड करो एंड वहां पे रिपोर्ट करो वहां
आपके चांसेस जो है ज्यादा इंक्रीजड हो
जाएंगे ओपन बक बाउंट पे जो है प्रैक्टिस
के लिए कर सकते हो हालांकि वहां पे शायद
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करेंगे आपका बट ठीक है फिर
भी ट्राई मारने में कोई कुछ नहीं जाता
हमारा बट ठीक है फिर भी आप ट्राई करो तो
बग क्राउड पे अगर मिल गया फिर तो आपकी
बाउंट 110 पर लिखी है मतलब उसको कोई रोक
नहीं सकता है ठीक है
गॉट इट बक क्राउड के लेस वेजिटेट टारगेट
पर हंट करो हां बिल्कुल बक क्राउड के लेस
वेजिटेट टारगेट पर हंट करो बहुत सही है
बहुत सही बात है बक क्राउड पे ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स को फाइंड करो जहां पे बहुत कम
हैकर्स विजिट करते हो डेली बेसिस पे
पुराने प्रोग्राम्स हो बहुत लेस पॉपुलर
प्रोग्राम्स हो सबसे क्योंकि बग क्राउड पे
ना यार एक दो प्रोग्राम नहीं है बग क्राउड
पे हजारों प्रोग्राम्स हैं सबसे जो एकदम
जिनको कोई नहीं जानता कुछ नहीं जानता ना
उसपे हंट करो ना यहां पे शॉर्ट डेट जो है
स्टार्ट डेट स्टार्ट कब हुआ था भैया एंड
असेंडिंग ऑर्डर में तुमने यहां पे करी
दिया है तो सबसे पहले ब क्राउडी स्टार्ट
हुआ था स्टेटस पेज फॉक्सी कट ये सब
स्टार्ट हुए थे बहुत पहले सब स्टार्ट हुए
थे इनमें जो सबसे कम पॉपुलर हो ना जिसके
बारे में ज्यादा आपको नहीं सुनने है ये
क्या है स्टेला एंटिस बहुत कम लोग मतलब
बहुत कम आपने देखा होगा कि किसी ने इसमें
कुछ निकाला है या कुछ ऐसे फाइंड किया इसको
खोल लो देखो भाई इसका क्या हिसाब किताब चल
रहा है मतलब इसके अंदर में क्या चीजें हैं
क्या हिसाब किताब चल रहा है अ देखो यहां
पे क्राउड नीचे आके देखो p3 में 400 से
बाप रे ये तो अच्छी खासी दे रहे हैं ये तो
ड conect.com इनकी वेबसाइट वगैरह देखो कि
क्या है भाई इनकी वेबसाइट प कुछ इस तरीके
का हालाकि इसमें कुछ है ही नहीं ऑप्शन ही
नहीं है कुछ फीचर ही व अपलोड वगैरह का कुछ
है नहीं यहां प शायद मेरे ख्याल से जहां
पर अपलोड का कुछ इमेजेस अपलोड कर पाए वो
चीज आप ट्राई कीजिएगा ठीक है एंड वहां पे
हंट करने की कोशिश करो एंड यू माइट गेट द
वैलिड लेबिलिटी ठीक है आज तो यार 100 प्लस
अभी तक है क्या हो गया भाई क्या बात है
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक था ना लव फ्रॉम
पाकिस्तान लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर सर यू आर
द बेस्ट टीचर आप से सीखने को बहुत कुछ मिल
रहा है थैंक यू सो मच ब्रदर सर इतना अच्छा
यबर कहीं और नहीं
मिलता फहद अहमद थैंक यू सो मच ब्रदर फॉर
योर काइंड
वर्ड्स
ओके वीपीटी की जो हमारी पेड ट्रेनिंग है
उसकी अनाउंसमेंट बहुत जल्दी आने वाली है
बहुत जल्द आने वाली है वो सबके लिए है जो
बग बाउंट में इंटरेस्ट रखते हैं याद
रखिएगा जो भी बहुत ही खतरनाक ट्रेनिंग लच
होने वाला है वो बहुत खतरनाक ट्रेनिंग है
वो याद रखिएगा यह
चीज क्या हुआ
जॉब कैसे मिलेगी जॉब स्किल पर मिलेगी
टैलेंट पर मिलेगी जॉब मिलेगी भैया टैलेंट
और स्किल पर जॉब मिलेगी भैया बिल्कुल
मिलेगी ठीक है चलिए अब यह मुझे बताइए कि
इस वनबिल को आप इस लव फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश लव
फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर नेक्स्ट आएगा तीन महीने के बाद
पल्लव नहीं सॉरी नेक्स्ट 6 महीने के बाद
जो हमारी वीपीटी की ट्रेनिंग आने वाली है
वो सिक्स मंथ्स की लाइव ट्रेनिंग है सिक्स
मंथ्स की इंक्लूडिंग अ इंटर्नशिप जॉब
ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग प्रोग्राम आपकी यह आने
वाली है जो बहुत ही शानदार होने वाली है
पहली बार जॉब
ओरिएंटेड ठीक है तो ये बता दीजिए जल्दी से
पहले आपको ये लेबिलिटी समझ में आई और इस
पे आप प्रैक्टिस करेंगे क्लास के बाद
क्योंकि बहुत इजी लेबिलिटी है बट अगर आपने
निकाल ली ना टाइम देना पड़ेगा दिमाग लगाना
पड़ेगा पुराने टारगेट्स को ढूंढना पड़ेगा
वहां हंट करना पड़ेगा एंड देन आपके चांसेस
बनते हैं एंड वहां पे आपको बाउंट मिल सकती
है याद रखिएगा मैं आपको फिर से बोल रहा
हूं मैं आपको फिर से बोल रहा हूं मैं आपको
फिर से बोल रहा हूं आपको समझ में आई कि
नहीं ये वलने बिलिटी आप इस पर प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे कि नहीं आज के क्लास के बाद मुझे
बताइए नेक्स्ट क्लास के पहले तक अगर नहीं
बताएंगे तो फिर मैं यही पर रुका रहूंगा
बताइए सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिएगा 100 से
ज्यादा लोग हैं और लाइक ठोकते हुए रिप्लाई
कीजिए रिप्लाई करके लाइक ठोक
दीजिए नहीं रिप्लाई बहुत कम आता है यार यह
बहुत दुख दुख दुख दुख की बात है बहुत दुख
की बात है भाई रिप्लाई तो काफी कम आते
हैं अंडरस्टैंड आई विल ट्राई ठीक है
बिल्कुल
एटी इंजेक्शन रिपोर्ट करो ना ए इंजेक्शन
रिपोर्ट करो करेंगे बढ़िया देखो 100 से
ज्यादा लोग हैं बट रिप्लाई बहुत कम लोग कर
रहे हैं कोई बात
नहीं ठीक है चलेगा लाइक ठोक दिया सबने
लाइक तो ठोक ही दिया होगा सबने आज तो 200
लाइक भी होने वाले हैं भाई क्या बात है
यार तुम लोग ऐसे अगर करोगे तो तो मुझे कुछ
ज्यादा मतलब फ्रीक्वेंसी
रख रहे हो तुम लोग तो मजा आ रहा है
मुझे वीपीटी वनबिल असेसमेंट एंड
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग वीपीटी का ट्रेनिंग
सिर्फ पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग नहीं है गाइ
वलने बिलिटी असेसमेंट भी है उसमें
पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग भी है और वो
इंडस्ट्री लेवल की जो ट्रेनिंग है वो होने
वाली है वो आपकी नॉर्मल ट्रेनिंग नहीं है
इंडस्ट्री में जो काम आता है जो टूल्स पे
जिस तरीके से टेक्निक से काम आते हैं जैसे
अगर आप एक सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर के तौर पे
कहीं किसी कंपनी में किसी भी बड़े कंपनी
में आप मान लो डेल वाइट है डेल वाइट में
आपकी जॉब हो गई मान लो एज अ सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट विपो में हो गया एचसीएल में हो
गया फोस में हो गया आप वहां जो काम करेंगे
ना सिलेक्शन के बाद जो आपको प्रोजेक्ट पे
काम जिस तरीके से करना पड़ेगा वो सेम
तरीका हम आपको इस वीपीटी ट्रेनिंग में
सिखाने वाले हैं इंडस्ट्रियल टूल्स एंड
टेक्निक्स एंड
अप्रोचेबल कैसे होता है वो सब कराने वाले
हैं क्योंकि जो ट्रेनर होने वाले हैं आपके
वो ऑलरेडी 3 साल से ज्यादा इसी इंडस्ट्री
में काम कर रहे हैं अभी भी सीनियर
सिक्योरिटी कंसल्टेंट है कंसल्टेंट
है सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट इंजीनियर के भी
ऊपर वाला जो पोस्ट होता है कंसल्टेंट है
एंड वो आपको खतरनाक धमाकेदार तरीके से ऐसी
चीजें सिखाएंगे कि आप सोच भी नहीं सकते
हैं ठीक है बस तो बस वेट कीजिए थोड़ा
अनाउंसमेंट का
दैट्ची 50 ही रहेंगी तो जितना जल्दी आना
है आज आ जाइएगा लेकिन यह उनके लिए है
जिनको हल्का बेसिक आइडिया है मतलब
कंप्यूटर साइंस का मतलब कंप्यूटर्स का
साइबर सिक्योरिटी का हल्का बेसिक नॉलेज है
एंड उनकी प्री रिक्विजिट यही है कि हमारी
बग बाउंट की सीरीज को आप फॉलो कर रहे हैं
एटलीस्ट उसको रेगुलर बेसिस पे नॉर्मली देख
रहे हैं यही उसकी एक प्री रिक्विजिट्स है
एकदम जिनको बिल्कुल जीरो आता है बग बाउंट
मतलब कंप्यूटर में कुछ नहीं जानते उनके
लिए वो कोर्स नहीं है वो ट्रेनिंग नहीं है
जिनका बेसिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी में हल्का
है नॉलेज है हल्की-फुल्की एंड वेब पेन
टेस्टिंग में हल्की-फुल्की नॉलेज है जैसे
बाउटी सीरीज को ही फॉलो कर लो देख लो ट्स
इट इनफ बग माउंटी की तुम 10 10 20 वीडियो
भी देख रहे हो देख लिए हो ट्स इट इनफ है
तो जिनको आना होगा वो अभी बग बाउटी की
सीरीज को भी देखिएगा बस यही बोलूंगा ठीक
है प्रिल एलेशन ठीक है आ
जाएगा भाई ई पीटी लेवल की ट्रेनिंग लेकर
आने वाले हैं फ्री वाली इसके इसके साथ
अनाउंस होगी मतलब यह जो बग बाउटी चल रही
है इसके साथ साथ वो भी आएगी सोच रहे हो ना
क्या मतलब बहुत कुछ अभी आएगी यार अभी तुम
देखते तो जाओ अभी
फी कितनी होगी फी 15000 होगी वीपीटी
ट्रेनिंग की टू बी कैन बी गिवन इन सिंपली
थ्री मंथली इंस्टॉलमेंट्स 5000 ईच 5000 ईच
का मंथली इंस्टॉलमेंट होगा 15000 फी होगी
यह हमने काफी कम फी रखी है अकॉर्डिंग टू द
ट्रेनिंग जो हम क्योंकि हम ना आपको एक तरह
का यू कैन से इंडस्ट्रियल ट्रेनिंग दे रहे
हैं प्रॉपर इंडस्ट्रियल ट्रेनिंग
कॉर्पोरेट ट्रेनिंग जो भी बोलना है बोल लो
एंड जॉब ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग एंड इसकी जो
इंटर्नशिप होगी उस इंटर्नशिप में चांसेस
आर देयर कि हर एक बंदे को एक वैलिड बग
मिलेगा हर एक बंदे को एक वैलिड मिलेगी
चीजें क्योंकि हम आपको उसी तरीके से शेप
अप करेंगे हो सकता है बाउंट भी मिल जाए और
आपका वह पैसा रिकवर भी हो जाए ऐसा भी हो
सकता है मैं कुछ गारंटी नहीं दूंगा नहीं
तो बाद में मेरे ऊपर आ जाते हैं लोग तो यह
पॉसिबिलिटी मतलब बहुत अलग लेवल की आपको
ट्रेनिंग मिलने वाली है बहुत अलग लेवल
की सिक्स मंथ्स की ट्रेनिंग होगी ये फोर
मंथ ट्रेनिंग चलेगी टू मंथ्स आपका
इंटर्नशिप एंड मॉक अप मॉक अप राउंड आपका
मॉक अप राउंड चलेगा जो बेसिकली मॉक
इंटरव्यूज वगैरह
होते हैं इंटरव्यूज वगैरह के लिए प्रिपेयर
आपको कराया जाएगा एंड आपका इंटरव्यू हम
ट्राई करेंगे कहीं-कहीं आपको इंटरव्यू के
लिए अप्लाई करवाने का वो सारी चीजें एंड
फिर देखते हैं स्पेशली थर्ड ईयर फाइनल ईयर
प्री फाइनल ईयर फाइनल ईयर एंड कॉलेज
पासआउट वालों के लिए ये इंटरव्यू वाली चीज
होगी अब 12थ वाले जो होंगे उनको इंटरव्यू
तो नहीं दिला सकते क्योंकि वो एलिजिबल ही
नहीं होंगे वो फ्रीलांसिंग कर सकते हैं
लाइक अपनी फ्रीलांसिंग करनी हो सर्विसेस
देनी हो प वीपीटी के सर्विसेस दूसरे
कंपनीज को देनी है वो स्टूडेंट्स अगर हैं
अगर 12थ के हैं या जो भी है कॉलेज में तो
व अपनी फ्रीलांसिंग वाली के लिए यह कर
सकते है ठीक
है ओके हैक द बॉक्स पहले ट्राई मी का
देखते हैं
पहले अब देखो एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी प आएंगी
क्या हा जी एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पर भी आएंगे
यार स्पैम तो मत करो यार मैंने कई बार
बोला है स्पैम करोगे तो भगा दिए जाओगे
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पर भी आएगी
टेंशन नहीं लेना
है ठीक
है सर बग बा बाउंट रिपोर्ट कैसे बनाना है
आप सारी वीडियोस लगता है मुझे नहीं देखते
हो इसलिए आपको नहीं पता है आप सारी
वीडियोस देखिए हमारे चैनल इस लाइव सेक्शन
के आपको पता चल जाएगी ऑलरेडी स्पे स्पेशल
वीडियो बनी हां
निशा कौन सी साइट निर्क कौन सी साइट विजिट
करनी है मुझे नहीं पता कौन सी साइट बोला
बिल्कुल आग लगेगी साइबर सिक्योरिटी वाली
इसमें बिल्कुल लाइव आग लगेगी
आई होप टू मीट यू वन डे सर इट्स अ बिग
ड्रीम ऑफ माइन थैंक यू फॉर एवरीथिंग थैंक
यू ब्रदर केविन साइबर
वरियर कौन सी लिंक भेजी है भैया लिंक कौन
सी भेजी है क्या लिंक है ये
कौन सी लिंक है
यह बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया यह बढ़िया है
बढ़िया इस पर ट्राई इस पर ट्राई करो इस पर
कर सकते हैं इस पर ट्राई कर सकते हो अगर
है तो बढ़िया ऐसे ही निकालो
ऐसे ही निकालो बढ़िया चीज है सो सही है
गाइस आई होप की यू लर्न समथिंग
एंड यू लर्न समथिंग नहीं इसका कुछ इशू
होगा नि शार काभी इसलिए नहीं ओपन हो रहा
होगा एक बार फिर से ट्राई करना हो जाएगा
क्योंकि वो ओपन ना होना तो वैसे कोई उसमें
हम कुछ नहीं कर सकते अगर ओपन नहीं हो रहा
तो बट कुछ इश्यूज होंगे है
ना एज लिमिट नहीं होती है 15 के कॉस्टली
सर कॉस्टली नहीं है बहुत बहुत चीप है जो
कंटेंट आपको मिलने वाला है ना 15k में
वीपीटी में सेम कंटेंट आपको सेम प्राइस
में सेम लेवल की चीजें आपको कोई भी दे दे
आपको फुल मैं रिफंड कर दूंगा मैं कर दूंगा
आपको ₹1 नहीं रखूंगा फुल 15k रिफंड मैं
इसकी गारंटी देता हूं ऐसे थोड़ी ना यार हम
पूरी रिसर्च करके फी को रखते हैं एंड
क्योंकि हमने ऑलरेडी एक टैग लाइन दिया है
ना मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल और फ्री कोर्स तो फ्री
कोर्सेस आपको डेनिक्स अकेडमी के थ्रू
मिलती है मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल हम अपनी
ट्रेनिंग कोर्सेस को बनाने की कोशिश पूरी
करते हैं अभी तक सारे हमारे अफोर्डेबल है
जो आपको कंटेंट क्वालिटी मिलती है ठीक है
बस इतना चीज है अब कोई मान लो कोई छ महीने
का कोई छ महीने का कोर्स है जिसमें 1000
मॉड्यूल है मान लो जस्ट एग्जांपल मैं दे
रहा हूं इसका बात नहीं इसकी बात नहीं कर
रहा मैं 1000 मॉड्यूल है उसकी फी किसी ने
लाख रप रख दि है तो वो गलत नहीं रखा है वो
एक लाख उसके कंटेंट के हिसाब से व कम है
ठीक है तो यह मेन चीज य कंटेंट पर फोकस
करना है
आपको ठीक
है क्या भाई करण करण क्या रिप्लाई करूं
मैं कुछ क्वेश्चन तो है हाय करण करणा
सम्राट एसोसी एनालिस्ट ठीक है उसपे भी
लाते हैं चलिए ठीक है गाइस तो आज के सेशन
के लिए बस इतना ही आज के सेशन को हम यहां
एंड करते हैं बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद इतने लोग
आए और नेक्स्ट क्लास में और भी खतरनाक एक
चीज लेकर आऊंगा बताऊंगा आपको वो क्लास भी
आप हर क्लास में आ आइएगा यार हर क्लास में
आपको ना कुछ ना कुछ बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें ही मिलने वाली है याद रखिएगा ये चीज
ठीक है तो मजा आ गया आज के सेशन में काफी
लोग आए हैं काफी लोगों ने इतना सपोर्ट
प्यार दिखाओगे तो कंटेंट भर लग जाएगी
कंटेंट इतनी आएगी कि सोच भी नहीं सकते हो
मैं गारंटी इस बात की देता हूं आपको और
क्वालिटी के साथ आएगी ऐसा नहीं आएगा कि
फ्री में दे रहे तो कुछ भी दे रहे हैं
बाकी लोगों की तरह पागल बनाया जा रहा है
बिल्कुल नहीं डि फ्रक्स पागल बनाने के लिए
नहीं जो पागल बनाते हैं उनकी दुकान बंद
करने के लिए जानी जाती है ठीक है तो उनकी
दुकान भी बंद करेंगे हालांकि मेरा कोई ऐसा
प्राइम मोटो नहीं होता किसी का दुकान बंद
करना मैं अपने आप वो दुकानें बंद हो जा
रही है तो मुझे मैं इसमें क्या कर सकता
हूं लोगों की बग माउंटी की दुकानें बंद
हुई है काफी लोगों की जो कुछ भी दे दे रहे
थे पा पा 00 लेके तो बंद हो रही है तो
फिलहाल के लिए आज के सेशन के लिए बस इतना
ही बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद आज आप लोग पधारे एंड
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट अ सेशन में बहुत जल्द
एक नए वनबिल एक नए क्लास के साथ एंड थैंक
यू सो मच गुड नाइट खाइए पीजिए ऐश कीजिए
एंड इस वनबिल पे काम कीजिए इस वलने बिलिटी
पे ट्राई कीजिएगा एक नॉर्मल सा सैंपल इमेज
डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा यहां से एंड कहीं से
कोई सा भी एंड इसमें मेटा डाटा सारी होंगी
इसको अपलोड इसी को अपलोड कीजिएगा जो भी
टेस्ट साइट्स है ना इन सब इमेजेस को ही
अपलोड कीजिएगा जो ये आपकी नॉर्मल टेस्ट
साइट्स है अपनी क्या ही इमेज अपलोड
कीजिएगा जो टेस्ट इमेजेस हैं अपलोड
कीजिएगा अगर डाउन अपलोड करने के बाद जब
फिर उस इमेज को आप देखिए उसका जब मेटा
डाटा निकालिए अगर उसमें लोकेशन नहीं आ रही
है मतलब वो सिक्योर है अगर लोकेशन फिर भी
आ रही है इसका मतलब है कि वह अनसिक्योर है
वल्नरेबल है उसको आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है एंड आपको बाउंट या रिवॉर्ड जो भी
है मिल जाएगी धन्यवाद गाइ एवरीबॉडी
धन्यवाद एंड